my phone like this
good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the planning committee if the fire
alarm is activated please locate the
offices via the stairs either the
security door over here
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no thank you
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
would any member who wishes to speak
under Council procedure rule 20.1 please
announce it now before you do I have
already for item 4A councilor Smith and
Pew item for M counselor presslin item
for L counselor Pew and item five
Council appew are there any others
thank you
the following
the following application has been
reserved for public speaking
item four a land on the west side of
Topsail Street Ramsgate item 4B recommet
recycling center wood Church Road
birchington
item 4C plot 6 land adjacent to Cliff
top North Fallen Avenue broadstairs item
4D 32 Crow Hill broadstairs item 4 L
land north of downbarton Road Saint
Nicholas at Wade and item for M16 Seoul
Street broadstairs
I have apologies from councilor Dennis
with no substitute do I have any other
apologies
thank you
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you councilor uzeki
thank you chair yeah as as explained at
the beginning item 4D I'd like to
recluse myself on that one thank you
thank you
do members agree that the minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on the
19th of April 2023 be approved as a
correct record do I have a proposal for
that
Council Auburn and a seconder
counselor bayford thank you
any site visits will take place for
committee members on the 7th of July
the planning applications manager will
now outline the point of information
regarding the applications at 54 Stone
Road broadstairs item for a land on the
west side of Topsail Street Minster an
item for M16 Seoul Street broadstairs
chair so point of information about 54
Stone Road broadstairs which was voted
on at the April planning committee
meeting for a site visit so this
application has been appealed by the
applicant for non-determination of the
application by the council with the
application now being determined by the
planning inspectorate we'll update
members when we receive the start date
of the appeal but therefore no cybers it
will occur by the planning committee on
the application
point of information on item four a land
on the west side of tots Hill Street
subsequent to the publishing of the
agenda the councils received further
clarification on The Works to the bridal
way following a meeting and agreement
between the parish council kcc's public
rights of way officer and the applicant
and this will be outlined in the
presentation by the principal planning
officer
and the last update for item 4M which is
16 Seoul Street broadstairs we've
received confirmation that the
contribution to the Strategic access
management and monitoring plan for the
development on the site has been paid
and therefore there's no reason to defer
the application back to offices for
approval subject to either getting that
payment or a new legal agreement and
therefore the recommendation to members
is updated for the development to be
approved subject to the safeguarding
conditions in the committee report thank
you chair
thank you
moving on to item agenda 4A
and on the west side of Topsail Street
Ramsgate beginning with speaking in
favor of the application is mizami
taplin Tamplin and I'll remind you that
you have three minutes thank you
chairman members of the committee good
evening and thank you for the
opportunity to speak this evening my
name is Amy Tamplin and I represent the
applicant David Wilson homes
I'd like to thank the planning officer
for their extensive report and
recommendation for approval I will not
repeat the details of the report rather
reiterate and respond to some of the key
points as you're aware the site is one
that already benefits from outline
planning permission the application
before you this evening considers the
detailed layout scale appearance and
Landscape in a phase one providing 133
residential dwellings this development
has been designed to comply with the
parameters set out within the outline
ensuring that development is sensitive
to the context in particular the
surrounding residents and Landscape this
buying Road has speed reduction features
utilizing the site access approved and
discussed at the outline stage and many
of the internal streets have been
designed as shared services to create a
safe environment for all users
concerns were raised by both councilors
and the planning officer regarding the
levels and the relationship between the
proposed development and the existing
properties on Fairfield Road we work
proactively with the plan and officer to
reduce the ground levels in this area
and provide additional boundary
treatments to enhance the Privacy for
both existing and new residents
another main concern from residents was
the right-of-way enhancement works I
attended a meeting on behalf of David
Wilson last week along with the public
right of way officers and Parish
councilors and discussed the preferred
approach additional surveys are now
underway and discussions will be ongoing
with KCC public right-of-way to ensure
the character and history of the bridal
way is retained
initial concerns were raised by
councilors and the housing officer in
regard to the affordable housing mix
however I can confirm that the proposal
is policy compliant and following
discussions with both the planning and
housing officer additional one-bed
Apartments have been added and
confirmation has been sought that the
current mix addresses local needs
there are a range of high quality
materials and elevational enhancements
such as bay windows on those railings
that front top Hill Street which are in
keeping with the surrounding Village all
dwellings are supported by private and
communal electric charging points
promoting sustainability the design also
includes substantial areas of open space
offering a variety of formal and
informal open space with pedestrian
links to the bridal way as well as an
equipped play area incorporating a range
of ecological enhancements and
sustainable drainage features across the
site
throughout the planning process we work
proactively with officers responding to
queries raised and would ask members to
note that there are no objections from
KCC highways the environment agency KCC
drainage nor indeed any of than its own
officers overall the application
provides much needed homes within a
sustainable location within the district
and I would urge members to support the
office's recommendation in granting
approval this evening thank you
thank you uh speaking under a council
rule 20.1 first is councilor Abby Smith
three minutes
thank you thank you chair and um thank
you very much Ms taplin it's really
helpful to and encouraging to hear what
you had to say I am here
um purely because uh Minster Parish
Council is unable to attend this evening
and I just want to reiterate what has
been said to me and what has become very
clear both from the uh Parish Council
itself and from
um residents who have attended Parish
Council that it is very important that
the character and history of the uh
Bridal way is retained and that the
Hedgerow in particular is retained and I
wasn't a hundred percent and I have read
and re-read the correspondence on this
and I'm really in 100 certain that
that's uh guaranteed but I just like the
planning committee to be aware that
that's an important factor and with that
thank you
thank you councilor Smith Council appeal
thank you chair I'd like to reiterate
much of what uh councilor Smith has said
um I'm very relieved to hear that the
applicant has taken on board the views
of Minster Parish Council and of the
council and of
the ward councilors particularly in
their concerns about the uh the heights
of some of the buildings back in onto
Fairfield Road I think that's really
encouraging that changes have been made
I'm also very glad to hear that changes
will be made or not to the bridal path
and that it won't be filled in I think
it's really important that you know
particularly uh local geological kind of
Heritage within the villages is
respected and maintained as much as
possible
um so if all of that has been agreed
um then I'm I'm happy for this
application to be approved thank you
thank you I'll now ask the principal
planning officer to outline the report
thank you chair this is the application
site here outlined in Red so tophill
street is on the right hand side of this
slide and the bridal way being referred
to is along the western boundary of this
slide and to the north you can see the
cemetery and the area in the blue line
is
um the area that formed the expansion
area for the cemetery through the
outline application
so this is an aerial view of the site so
you can see top Hill Street again on the
right hand side with the cemetery and to
the North's slide and the right away
runs along in this location here and the
application site extends along these
boundaries and so this application is a
for phase one of of the development so
it's only in this location here for the
actual development itself
this is just a more detailed aerial view
showing top Hill Street so you can see
the cemetery on the right hand side and
we've talked Hill Street at the bottom
this slide so it's just reorientated
slightly and just so you can see the
existing neighboring properties in the
area along Fairfield Road and again to
the um to the other side of Hill Street
so these are some photos going around
the site so this is taken
um sorry going back here this we're in
this top corner here and we're going to
walk down the bride away with these
photos so
um we're by the a299 and the application
site is in the distance here and this is
the bridal way running to the site so
and this is another view with the
application site here again the bridal
way on this right hand side here
so walking down the ride away you can
see existing agricultural Fields either
side so these aren't part of the
application it's beyond this fenced area
here
and this is now the application sites
you can see some work has taken place
magnitude of archeologies and some other
exploration work within the site again
you can see the bride away Along here
and the fencing around the site so from
visiting the site ktc have advised that
the actual Bridal way is on the boundary
of the site so the actual boundary of
the application site is actually in this
location here where the bridal way
exists but it's been set the fence has
been set further away from the bridal
way just to give a bit of protection and
continued use of the Bride away
so again views into the site here
um
I'm sorry go the wrong way
and here again so you can see there's
quite a lot of existing vegetation
adjacent to the boundary and this is the
concern that's been raised from
residents through the original plans it
was intended to remove quite a lot of
this because the proposal was to to
widen the bride away so
going down here again you can see
existing and trees there's no mature
trees along here but quite a lot of
growth so when you get to this point
here the actual bridaway is actually to
the left here so this is an area that's
now been used by people so it's an
informal path but the actual Broadway
runs through the center of this
vegetation and is quite overgrown so
it's quite difficult for it to have been
used
um so again you can see here so this on
the left hand side is the existing
Bridal way this is the area on the right
hand side it has actually been used as a
path because of the fact this is quite
overgrown and so KCC have confirmed that
this would be added
um to every year to their clearance
program so they would be looking to come
out and actually clear this to make this
usable
and again further down heading down the
site and again the bride away is on the
left hand side here
and then we get towards the bottom of
the site coming out now
um close to Prospect Road so then this
is looking back and so back towards
Prospect Road
and then again all the actual
application site itself so looking over
to the properties in Green Hill Gardens
and then again just looking back up
north of the site and now we're in
Prospect Road with the bride away in
this location here and this the
application site on the right hand side
and then this is just the view again
with the application site here and the
bridal way off to the left-hand side so
now moving around the site we're just
going to go along Greenhill Gardens so
the bottom of this point here and come
up Green Hill Green Hill gardens around
Prospect Road
so
um this is taken on the corner looking
with prospect prospect sorry Green Hill
Gardens on the right hand side and this
is the another existing path on the
left-hand side and this is the
application site in front of us
and now we're heading up um Greenhill
Gardens
so through the approved outline
application there's an emergency access
vehicular access point in this location
here
and then heading up the road so you can
see Green Hill Gardens consists mainly
of Bungalows and Shadow style Bungalows
and then as we come into Fairfield Road
you can see there's more of a mix of
dwelling types so you've got Bungalows
and then it turns into two-story
dwellings towards the end of Fairfield
Road
and now just coming out of Fairfield
Road into top Hill Street so we're in
this location here
these are the properties in Fairfield
sorry in Hill Street on the corner with
Fairfield Road so you can see there's a
mix of terrorists and somebody touched
properties mainly brick but render and
you can see there's quite a few Bay
features on the properties
and then again just a a longer view of
the sites of the application sites now
is on the left hand side here just
beyond these properties
and now this is the application site in
this location here
and now this is just showing the the
nearest neighboring property on top Hill
Street and you can just see
um the ground level changes so there's a
small retaining wall along this property
with the ground level within the
application sorry higher than the
neighbors and you could see from that
previous slide as well that the ground
level changes from
um from Fairfield Road in this location
here up to the application sites there's
a big round level change
and then this is now just going up the
site with the application site again on
the left and then just looking back down
the site with the application on the
right just showing the variety of
building styles and properties in the
area
and then just a further view again of
the application site so the access into
the site would be on the right hand side
here and the proposal is looking to
retain Hedgerow along
um this front boundary
and then a further view again
so just to quickly Show members the
outline approval so this was the outline
parameter plan that was approved
um the access was approved as part of
this application it was approved for 214
dwellings
um the access was approved in this
location here so what this plan is is
just showing the parameters that were
approved through the outlines so the
area in yellow is the area that can be
no longer no more than 1.5 stories in
height and this was because of the
proximity of the bungalows in Green Hill
Gardens and The Limited
um depth of their Gardens it was felt
necessary to reduce the
um or restrict the height of development
in that location and then the area in
red you can see the long strip here in
the two circles here these are the areas
that are archaeological exclusion zones
so during the application and the work
that was carried out found that these
areas were so significant they can't be
developed upon so these areas are
excluded from development other than the
access road which has been allowed to be
extended across this point here
so also a preview that application was
the actual access vehicle access into
the site so this shows the vehicular
access so through this application there
have been some concerns raised by
residents regarding the access and the
fact there's no central island
um to the center of the access so we did
seek the views from KCC obviously the
access has already been approved so we
couldn't change that anyway but just to
seek their advice on it and they advised
that the width of the access is is
similar to other accesses without
um pedestrian Islands being being
visible and also if there was to be a
progesterone in the center it would
restrict the movement of larger Vehicles
into the site so it would actually cause
more problems and the safety order that
was carried out the time found that to
be fine so that is that is the approved
access and then just so you're aware
because I know other concerns that were
raised to do the impact on highway
from Top Hill Street being such a busy
road and additional Vehicles being added
to the shoot but through that
application just so you you know the
music that was approved was through the
widening of the access leading onto the
roundabout so this is Hill Street and
this is the application site in this
location here and the mitigation secured
um the widening of this to create an
additional Lane which would help to
reduce
um traffic cues along top Hill Street
and the mitigation also secured money
towards the improvements to a Spitfire
way Junction as well
so this application is a reserve matters
application all we're looking at is the
layout and the scale and design of the
development as long as well as the
Landscaping
so um you can see this is the overall
um layout that's been proposed so this
is a phase one of the development which
is earned towards the north of the site
so the area in Gray is not being
considered as part of this application
and will come forward as part of a
future phase
um you can see the existing access in
this location here
and then areas of landscaping around the
edge of the site and to the south of the
site
so this application is for 133 dwellings
it's for a mix of unit sizes and types
all of them meet the space standards
they're all two-story in height they all
are provided with Dorset play space and
this plan shows the mix of the unit
sizes so there's a mix of the one two
three and four bed across the site and
concern was raised with the lack of one
bed units especially for the affordable
provision and that's been increased from
two units up to six units which housing
have agreed with so the affordable units
are located in the center here so
they're the pink units towards the
center so it did achieve 30 affordable
on the site so this application proposes
40 affordable units
foreign
space provision this plan just shows the
open space being provided across the
site so
um you can see the area in pink in this
location here around the edge of the
site is the area that's
um semi-natural open space and then
light green in this location here and
here and to the top here these areas are
the amenity space and then to the bottom
there will be a community Orchard and
then in the center here the purple and
within the future phase as an equipped
play area and a detailed plan for the
equip player has been submitted through
these applications they've shown a range
of equipment within the center of the
site
um so this is well accessible from Top
Hill Street and would also be accessible
through to the bride away as well so it
could be potentially accessed by the
existing Community as well as residents
of the site itself the open space
significantly exceeds the minimum
requirements set out within policy gio5
this is mainly because of the large
areas of the archaeological exclusion
zones which do limit the amount of
development on the site so there's very
large areas of open space all to the
south of the site
in terms of the layout of the houses
they all have Street Frontier just so
you can see on the right hand side
properties front onto top Hill Street
and they follow um the linear pattern of
development that exists in Top Hill
Street although they're set back
slightly from the road to allow for the
retention of um the Hedge and Boundary
treatment within the site itself
um the access runs through the center a
number of cul-de-sacs extending off of
this along the northern boundary this is
the boundary that the area of housing
that would be more visible from long
views from the countryside and so the
development in this location is a bit
more spacious when compared to the
center of the site where there's a few
more terrorist and smaller units
and there's landscape buffers as you can
see around the site so along the north
some buns and so again in the air in
pink you can see here that's the
archaeological exclusion area so buns
have been provided in this location in
order that tree planting can be provided
otherwise it would have interfered with
the archeology so this will actually
provide quite good screening and
softening of the development in The
Wider views and again you can see in
terms of actual tree planting tree-lined
streets which is encouraged within the
mppf and tree planting again in all of
the Open Spaces
so there's a variety of unit types I'm
just going to show you a few of the
Street Scenes being proposed so the
first one we're looking at is the actual
Tot Hill Street elevation Street
elevation and then it also shows the
internal Access Road elevation in this
location here
so this top one is the tophill street
elevation so we have worked to try and
um improve the variety of materials and
features within this elevation given the
fact it's
um it's the main most prominent
elevation of of the development and it's
in an area where three top Hill Street
there's a a large variety of building
types and so it's we're keen to make
sure that there's not just a row of
singular unit types here making it very
clear that it's a new development it
actually could look like they've all
been developed individually so we
requested that amendments were provided
to introduce additional bay windows
within the development and more varied
material so this now has render black
clad in and
red and brown brick and you can see like
Gable features within the center so it's
now felt that this elevation will work
well in the character of the area of top
Hill Street so the bottom of the slide
is the more internal Access Road
elevation so I'll just quickly flick
through these so again and just just
seeing the variety of unit types being
offered within the development so the
next three are showing this area here so
these three
um Street elevations to the back of the
site
so you can see here
um that they are there's a variety with
different style hip roofs
um with some with the bays at ground
floor level some with porches
and again you can see like the cladding
so the bottom Street Scene here is the
one that would be more visible from
outside the site to the north so again
you can see the use of the black cloud
in which is a bit more in keeping with
rural character and then the final one
is showing the long Access Road through
the middle of the site and both sides of
that so one so the E is the the top of
the access road and F is the bottom so
these are the ones running through the
middle so again you can just see
similar but they have there's a few with
some render a few Gable vanishes so it's
considered that the design is there's
enough variety within the development to
be suited to the character of The
Village and the scale of the units is
considered to be acceptable and this is
showing the variation of the material so
you can see the plain red multi-red and
brown brick being used within the
development along with red and gray
tiles and the render and dark clad in
across the development so it's
considered that that has enough variety
to be acceptable
um in terms of the impact on neighboring
properties the main concerns that have
been raised from residents have been to
do with overlooking to the properties in
Fairfield Road
so you can see the gardens
um for these existing properties are
quite long
um
there's currently
um a garden depth of around 34 meters
for these Gardens so from the rear
renovation of the of the existing
neighboring dwellings to the rear
elevation of the proposed development
there's approximately 42 meters
now that would normally be considered
well in excess of the minimum distance
we're looking for but the only
additional impact here is the fact that
there's the ground level change and that
these properties are on a higher ground
level than the existing residents and
that is one of the main concerns that
residents have raised so we did request
section plans to try and show the
relationship between the existing
properties and the neighboring
properties and so these are the
properties in Fair Fairfield Road which
as you remember were the Bungalows and
the two-story dwellings and these are
the section plans that we had submitted
so the three red lines are showing the
three different sections taken across
different parts of the properties in
Fairfield Road and these are the
sections so you can see the ground level
change you can see the um first floor
Windows of the development so the
developers have or the applicants have
reduced the height of the development
but all they could achieve was a 0.3
reduction in height because of the
ground level problems at the
um they're dealing with within the site
so they couldn't go down any further
because it would have caused some issues
with drainage and highways so they did
they've dropped that they've also
increased the rear boundary treatment so
it was originally 1.8 meters in height
and now it's gone up to 2.4 meters in
height and we have secured that through
a condition that would require that to
be provided and so it is considered
looking at these sections that's one of
the sections that's another section
and that's the third section so it is
considered that with the the slight
reduction High and the securing of the
boundary treatment at that particular
height and the oval distance the
unbalance the impact on residential
immunity and privacy is considered to be
acceptable
the other impact to look at is the
impact on the closest properties into
Hill Street here so and there's a 7.5
meter distance from the side elevation
of the nearest plot to the side of of
the of number one one four and a seven
meter Gap to the garage so these
distances are considered acceptable to
limit any impact on light and Outlook
there's some windows located in the side
elevation of this plot and this plot
here and so a condition has been added
to require those to be obscure glaze and
non-opening Below 1.7 meters the
permissive development rights has also
been removed for this plot here to
prevent them from being allowed to build
any side extensions that would move
closer to 114 so on that basis it's
considered the impact on that property
and these properties on top Hill Street
is acceptable
um High rates have been consulted
they've looked at the parking layout
within the development and parking is
provided on the basis of two parking
spaces per unit and one per flat there's
35 Vista parking spaces that are
provided and it did say 40 in the report
but actually 35 is the correct number
and Casey supervisor that they are happy
with that and have no concerns with it
the Vista parking spaces did increase
from 27 which were originally submitted
so there has been an increase in that
number on this plan you can see the
Vista parking spaces of the blue area so
they're mainly laid by parking close to
the equip play areas and the open space
and also just elsewhere along the access
roads just provide a variety throughout
the development
um
so highways have raised no concerns with
the parking tracking plans have been
submitted showing that Vehicles can turn
within development and that's been
considered acceptable and highways asked
for a raise table to be provided in this
location here in order to provide
traffic calming within development and
that has been provided along with this
busy space for all units and therefore
the impacts on highways is acceptable
the bridal way is one of the main issues
that's been raised through this
application so the brighter way you can
see on this plan here so this is a KCC
plan the bridal way is shown in Blue on
the left hand side of here so through
the legal agreement for the outline
application there was a requirement for
enhancements to the bridal way in the
form of widening to three meters and the
resurfacing of the Bride away a
financial contribution was secured for
the resurfacing and winding of the Bride
away in this location here which is
outside of the application site so that
would go to KCC and they would provide
those enhancement works but for the for
the brighter way that falls within the
application site so everything on the
western boundary it was required that
the applicant would have to do those
works so through this application
um originally it was submitted that
there would be the infilling of this
Bridal way in order to provide the
widening and the resurfacing as it was
felt that that was necessary in order to
allow for the right away to be easily
accessed from the development itself and
for exist in the existing right away to
be joined on to the development so you
can get good accessibility through the
development
um but there was obviously strong
objection from residents and Parish
Council to this so this is these are the
existing sections showing the bride away
so the bridal ways on the left hand part
of this slide so you can see that it is
a dip as you saw in the photos earlier
and so the proposal was to to infill
that space
um
this is the plan showing what would have
done what would have happened so this
would have been in field and that area
raised
but the concerns raised from resonance
is is that it would affected the
character of the Bride away and that
it's an ancient Bridal way and
um that you know strong strong concerns
with that have been raised so a visit a
site visit has taken place with uh KCC
public rights of way
and the applicant and
um the parish council and it's been
discussed whether the existing right
away could be retained as it is without
the infill works so options have been
provided by the applicant of the two
possibilities so this is the one
possibility option A
which is Ian filling so you can see the
three different sections of the
infilling works and then the other
proposal is to retain it as it is in
terms of the
um drop down level of the bridal way
retaining the vegetation on the boundary
as much as possible and on the left hand
side that would be retained anyway
because that falls outside the
application site
then the resurfacing of the bridal way
with
um the hogging surface material but it
probably wouldn't be widened to the
three meters because that's not going to
be achievable if we keep it at this
lowered level
now KCC public rights of way have come
back with a um a comment following the
publishing of the report and they've
advised that they are happy with this
option to keep it as is but just
resurface it with the hogging and they
feel that that will allow for improved
use of it
um but they do feel it needs to be wide
and slightly but they've accepted it
wouldn't need to be the fourth three
meters so a condition has been added to
this report
um
it's a
condition 12 and it's requiring full
details of the Bride away following
survey work that's going to be carried
out so full details of the design and
vegetation and the retention vegetation
so we'd get everything in showing how
it's going to be retained and how the
vegetation will be retain and we will
consult KCC
um for their comments on that but that
is the the intended approach now and I
think everybody's in agreement with that
Parish Council have also written into me
advising that they are also in agreement
of that approach so um hopefully that is
that is the solution it wouldn't involve
us having to
um sort of go back to the legal
agreement because there was a clause in
the legal agreement said that said to
best Endeavors that they would achieve
the three meters so to achieve something
slightly less than that if in agreement
with everybody else including KCC then
that would be
achievable so that is the the current
proposal so these were the three
sections just showing it as it is and
then this is the layout plan that would
show the connection into the development
so there would have to be footpaths that
would be dug out and some retaining
walls either side of the footpath just
to get down to that lower level but it
is achievable it might be that there's
slightly fewer connection points
potentially but it's a cheap but you can
get a few connections onto it at that
level
so it's considered that that is
acceptable KCC are happy with it um and
that's that's will be the approach so in
terms of just general Landscaping this
is the Landscaping master plan for the
site so you can see everything in green
is is um either tree plants in or you
can see hedge plants in along this
boundary here so this again the bride
away is the bottom of this slide now and
there's a proposal that would need a
four meter wide hedge along it which
will help to secure ecological
enhancements within the site
um a biodiversity method statement's
been submitted there's currently
um surveys that have shown there are
slow worms and reptiles within sight so
during construction they're all going to
be moved into the um Cemetery expansion
area and then they're going to be moved
back into the Open Spaces once the
developments um been completed so the
impact on biodiversity is is considered
acceptable there's enhancements as well
through this plan through
um
Wildflower planting and large areas like
that that will be secured for
biodiversity
and in terms of the drainage and the
final point there was again concerns
raised with residents regarding drainage
um so through this scheme The Proposal
was to provide basins in this location
here so on the right hand side of of
this screen at the bottom of the site
would be large basins and swells would
run along the boundary to the rear of
Green Hill Gardens and these would allow
surface water to be contained on the
site but eventually move into the
combined sewer they can't have all water
um a
infiltration on the site because there
will be a contamination issue because
there'd be too much and it's a
groundwater protection area so much of
the water will need to go into the
combined sewer and Southern water at the
moment have concerns because there's
lack of capacity in the area so they're
going to be carrying out a capacity
design assessment and working out where
the improvements need to be made the
developer will finance that and pay for
the the uh capacity improvements where
it's affected by the development and
that's going to be carried out
separately through a separate process
with Southern water so at the moment
there's not considered to be any
drainage issues the condition linked to
the outline has been discharged and the
approach that's been proposed through
this this application and through the
outline application is is considered to
be accepted
so overall um
the development is considered to be in
keeping with the area it achieves
um a large number of units which have
already been approved through the
outline application the impact on
residents could just be acceptable and
there's no other issues raised by any
other console T so it is recommended for
approval thank you
thank you I move that the officers
recommended recommendation is adopted
can I ask the vice chair to second that
please a seconded chair
thank you
um
does anyone want to speak right
Council of Garner sorry your name went
from here
thank you chair
um yeah I do have a couple of
um concerns and questions which I'd like
to just explore a little bit which then
might help me and others to make our
minds up about the um
the scale whether the scale of this
development is actually sustainable
going forward
and the Landscaping as well so I mean at
the end of the report there
um Emma mentioned about cyber mortar
um and
um flood risk of flooding but I did have
a look at the um Southern Water Report
from
13th of March
where they where they said that um
they'd undertaken a desktops desktop
study
uh and the additional the impact of the
additional
surface water flows from The Proposal
will have an existing will have on the
existing public sewer Network and they
show that there are there is likely to
be an increased risk of flooding as you
as you mentioned and they have said that
they do need as as you mentioned a
condition uh that would be phased and
implemented in the line with the
delivery of sewage Network reinforcement
that's required here so I mean I think I
don't need to I don't need to reiterate
the issues we have around here with
Southern water sewage we're all very
familiar with that and there is there
isn't any way that this isn't going to
have any anything other than an adverse
impact on the issues that we have unless
they combine any work they do to make
this development accessible with the
work that they need to do to um provide
all of us who already live in here with
a fit for purpose
um sewage system
um
so I am very concerned about that and in
fact I would it would be nice if they
could
um
Supply a bit more of a detailed report
which would outline
um how they're going to deal with this
extra sewage and what impact it might
have on the amount of sewage that's
released into the seal
already around our Coast to help us to
um come to a better better understanding
of whether this is sustainable
um
another question I have is around air
quality because I remember from the
right no I don't remember I looked
through and saw that one of the
conditions on the outline proposal
was that they were asked to provide an
air quality emissions statement and I
think that's relevant because we are
adding here 133 houses which are I mean
it's good to hear they've all got
charging points but the vast majority of
these houses won't have electric cars
most of them will have more than one car
and they they will all be
having an adverse effect on the air
quality of the area so I would be
interested to know if that emissions
report
has been produced already
um
now looking at looking at the uh
the slide you've got up there now I mean
there is there are a large number I mean
it's acceptable as you say
um as per
uh to the the size of each of these
plots but I suspect it's it's just about
acceptable they don't look
they do look a bit crammed to me what I
can't see from that is the gardens and
what what part of each of the plots is
in fact garden and that that as a new
that does have a bearing in terms of
linking in with this the flooding
because I do know when I look at some of
the other new new Estates that are being
built
there are minimal Gardens and maximum
[Music]
concrete
down around the back and the front of
the houses so could you give us an
indication of of the size of guard each
of the gardens else it looks like that
all the residents if they want a bit of
an open space rather than stepping out
the rather than stepping out the back
door into their Garden or the front door
they're gonna have to step out walk down
to uh
walk down to the quite substantial as
I'll admit that the Green Space around
around all the houses is there are there
opportunities for them to
I went to the open Gardens over that way
and there'd be nice if some of these
were able to have Gardens that they
would be able to make open term members
of the public at the Open Garden so are
there Gardens there that's what one of
the things I'd like to know and I'd also
like just confirmation the access at the
top there
on the hot the highway axis that is a
single access to oh tall 133 dwellings
in and out so the potential or the 200
potential 266 plus cars are all going to
enter this site through that single that
single axis which
not been overly familiar but I am I have
been up and down there a few times
it's always difficult to get up and down
because of parked cars on either side
there's everyone's giving away all the
time so another 200 plus houses is going
to add an issue accepting that KCC say
it's acceptable but um I think the the
scale it does have an impact on whether
the scale of the this development is in
fact sustainable and will that be the
same access to the upper 91 houses or
units that are going to be built in
phase two or did I notice another access
at the bottom of the site because that
that um would make a difference so for
now if we could there were a number of
questions there I know but if if you
could help with those I'd that would
help me formulate my opinion thank you
come back to you
okay um in terms of the drainage there
was a foul drainage condition on the
outline application that's not being
discharged yet so we've not had any
details of the foul drainage
um but what southern water have always
said is that they will not allow the
occupation of any of the dwellings until
the network reinforcement works for the
drain existing drainage have been
carried out so through the agreement
that they
um the applicant is going to have to
have with the um with Southern water
under the water industry at 1991.
um they would have an arrangement in
place that they can only occupy a
certain number of units as the
reinforcement works are carried out so
they will at no point be an issue with
um units being occupied with inadequate
drainage in the area so that will all be
dealt with through the conditions linked
to the outline and separately through
southern water through the water
industry Act
um in terms of air quality so I didn't
cover air quality because I was trying
to keep the presentation as short as I
could
um but a report was submitted with the
application which was the emissions
mitigation statement
um and that looked to the air quality uh
looked at air quality and basically sets
out what they're doing within the
development to try and reduce the impact
on air quality so through the air
quality assessment they identify a um a
mitigation cost which basically threw
the number of units what damage cost is
likely to be
created on air quality and they have to
use that cost to then provide things
within the development to try and reduce
it so it's not an actual Financial
contribution but it's they have to show
that they have provided things so that
can be in the form of landscaping
um it can be a pedestrian and cycle
routes to try and reduce people relying
on the car
um I mean they've also said within the
statement that because they're doing
um Financial contributions to improve
the highway Network that in itself will
reduce the impact on air quality so the
environment Health officer has raised no
concerns with the mitigation
um assessment that's been submitted
they're obviously also doing electric
vehicle charging which we now require as
a standard anyway for these types of
development and so the impacts on air
quality is dealt with and and considered
to be fine
um
in terms of your comment on Gardens so
they all have Dorset play Space every
single unit including the flats either I
don't know if you can see maybe this
plan is a bit too small but in the
center here these are the flats and the
gardens are divided so each of the flats
can get access to a garden so the top
floor would have to come out and walk
down a side access to get to it but they
all have Gardens there's no units
without its own garden
um in terms of the depth I think it
ranges around eight to ten meters
probably which is probably quite
standard for a new build unit it's not
the deepest of gardens but again you can
see that there is a lot of open space
within the site and you've got the
Dorset play space and the player is even
um so they all they have is a
requirement to provide the Dorset play
Space we don't have any minimum
standards for that so that they have
achieved it so that the garden is
considered to be acceptable and in terms
of access into the site so this is the
the main vehicular access into the site
and this would serve the whole
development including future phases but
this access right in down the bottom
here that's the emergency access so I
don't know if you can see it better
show it on it's not really highlighted
here but this one running through the
middle here comes out into Green Hill
Gardens and that would be the emergency
access so if there was ever ever a
problem
um in here and they needed to to you
know emergency vehicles to get into the
site and couldn't get into the site from
the front then that would provide that
emergency access
um but I believe the reason that there
was no additional main access provided
is that because of the issues in Minster
with vehicle movements it was considered
that the access in this location at the
top of top Hill Street most residents
would basically come out the access and
head straight out of the village so
you're not going to be blocking up the
center of the village where the
commercial area is they're going to be
heading straight out so it's actually
quite
a good location for an access where it
shouldn't be having a huge amount of
impact on the majority of top Hill
Street it's just at the top end of tott
Hill Street where they come out and head
straight out so that's um I believe why
that was probably agreed like that so
but again yeah that was agreed through
the outline so it's not really a
consideration for this application
thank you councilor Alban
all right thank you chair
um
I think obviously uh development
Saturday this is a
goes against the grain in relation to
the use of Farmland however that
particular issue has been taken out of
our hands
um
and overall looking at the whole of the
development as as out there
um
it's
the applicant has pretty much covered
everything everything within the
application that it needs to
um so I can't really see I'm looking for
a reason to refuse it and I can't
actually find one so that's all I'm
saying thank you chair
councilor Beaufort
thank you chair thank you enough for the
detailed presentation
I very much welcome the confirmation
that the Broadway will be retained and
enhanced I also welcome the retention of
many of the Hedge Rays Rose and the uh
sorry the
drop of the height of many of many of
the units
um the actors have been approved by KCC
personally I feel that this is a mix of
you of excellent mix of units
um including affordable housing
um the Landscaping is extensive uh and
the pop we have parking Gardens and I
personally welcome 133 dwellings which
were very very much needed thank you
counselor wing
thank you I always have to have a little
chuckle when I hear the term ecological
enhancements to wants to what once was
uh a grade Farmland it always makes me
chuckle a little and and make me quite
sad actually but you know that is out of
our hands could I ask what is the
present number of dwellings in Minster
does anybody know the present number
dwellings in Minster
[Music]
it appears not I because I'd like to
know
133 houses in one big lump with an a
number to follow probably represents a
significant percentage increase in the
number of dwellings in a village uh so I
wish we did have that number because
then we'd be able to put a percentage
figure on that I too have real concerns
about the lack of detail from Southern
water we know that the villages are are
serviced by their own water treatment
plant and as the report states there are
already capacity issues so I think if
this 33 plus the rest it represents a a
significant percentage in the in the
number of dwellings
uh in the village of Minster then we are
heading for a greater capacity issues
and I would certainly welcome greater
detail from Southern water before we can
sit here and make a decision I don't I
think it's a bit of of the horse the
horse before the cart to say build it
and we'll stop anybody living it in it
until the issues are dealt with I'm not
sure any of us would be doing that with
their own properties we'd be solving the
problem at first so it really does
concern me that we've got one phase of
building here where there are already
capacity issues with Southern water
with water needs and the deal and the
treatment of waste waste water and we're
going to allow this build to go ahead
without having that detailed information
that gives us a guarantee that what will
need to be done will be done
to protect the people that will be
living in these in these buildings and
also the existing owners the existing
residents plus our own environment and
our season waterways
uh so I I personally would like more
information could I also ask what's the
net gain of trees and hedgerows and is
there any uh Aftercare because we know
quite often you've only got a drive
through Westwood cross and see trees
that have never received any Aftercare
that are dead and die in so it's all
very well saying we're going to plant so
many trees and put the hedgerows in but
unless there is a commitment to four or
five years of Aftercare those trees and
hedgerows will disappear
uh
uh I I appreciate the fact that the
archaeological areas will be protected
that that's really good to know but but
how will they be protected
will they be left open will they will
they have hedgerows around them to
protect them will they be open grassland
I can't really see them in that
development there so how will these
archaeological areas be protected
uh also building 133 houses in a small
village I mean one we all know on our
own streets once somebody does some work
to their building it creates a right
kerfuffle on the street and upsets
everybody for a few months so what what
have we got in in place to mitigate
against uh deliveries Workforce parking
noise vibration dust uh in in such a
small village uh you know it's not a big
open area that all of this stuff has got
to come through the village and all of
this stuff has got to be worked on
within the village
uh
uh I think that's it they're my main
areas of concern my biggest area concern
is obviously the lack of detail from
Southern water
sorry hand back to the officers
uh sorry just to so to cover a few of
those points there so in terms of the
number of units so we don't know how
many
units are currently in the village but
in terms of this site it is a housing
allocation site that's why the outline
was approved and the
um
the policy for the housing allocation
was for 250 units and we've approved
214. so we've already approved well
below what the policy would have allowed
for so the policy would allow for a much
larger number of units on this but as I
said before this is because of
um the archaeological exclusion zones
that came to light probably after the
education policy was created which has
restricted how much the site can be
developed so you know it's for the
village it's better than it could have
been in terms of the archaeological
areas in terms of their protection they
don't actually need to be fenced off or
anything like that in terms of their
protection they just don't need they
can't be developed we can't dig down in
those areas so that's why they are areas
that are open Green Space and that's why
when I mentioned earlier about the Buns
so along the north where the red is
along the northern boundary in order to
get tree planting which we would
obviously want to see along the boundary
to help soften the development from
longer views they are going to be
building buns which again we have
conditions we can get details in of that
but that way they can plant the trees in
the buns and all the roots will go into
the buns and not go down underground and
not disturb the archeology so that is
how the archeology is being protected
but it's not it doesn't need to be
fenced off or anything like that so that
that is dealt with by just not being
developed
um and in terms of the impact from
construction vehicles they've already
submitted their construction and
construction management plan through the
condition that was attached to the
outline and that's been approved by
highways
um I don't have the details of that here
it should be online now for for people
to see
um because we've already approved it um
but I mean they would have looked at the
impact on the village and timings and
and things like that from for vehicle
deliveries
um because I know some residents have
already raised some concerns with
vehicles blocking areas when they were
doing the archaeological works and
things so it's understood that it's
something that residents are are
sensitive to
um so we would just you know make sure
if I make sure that we would enforce it
if there were concerns that residents
felt that they weren't complying with
the construction management plan and
obviously contact us and we will ask our
enforcement team to investigate it
um so in terms of first of all there is
a net gain of trees on the site just
straight off in terms of the number that
are on the site at the moment obviously
it's it's empty Farmland effectively so
there is a Net game of trees so there's
a very specific condition which is
usually put on major developments which
is more extensive than our normal
Landscaping condition which is condition
nine that's on the outline which is
about the provision of a landscape
ecological management plan which has to
be submitted before the first
occupational dwelling so that has to
include
um all sorts of details about management
actions work schedule objectives of the
management details of any body or
organization that's going to carry out
that work and continue to carry out on
this site through the 106 as well
there'll be the requirement for a
management company to maintain the areas
of open space so that's another sort of
hook that we have to control what comes
forward on the site
um I think the only other point was to
do is I suppose Southern water again
um I mean it in terms of I appreciate
the concerns with regards to
um I suppose it's about the role of
planning fundamentally planning has the
ability to mitigate further impacts of
what would be created by putting 133 or
in this instance 214 as per approved at
the outline we can mitigate that impact
and therefore the timing of getting the
mitigation before those drillings is
occupied is entirely in accordance with
case law about what we can and can't do
through this planning permission that
was granted outline so that's why it's
timed in the way that it is thank you
I I I'm a bit I don't I really
understand that maybe it's because I'm
not a planner but imagine six months
down the down the road Southern water
needs further detailed study says that X
Y and Z needs to be done but the houses
have already been built
and X Y and Z can't be done because the
house is already up there that's my
concern is that that uh
we need I feel that we need to know
exactly what needs to be done to address
the capacity issues which Southern water
and this planning application has
already identified exists
so it's not we're already in a bad place
and we're going to add additional houses
so it really really does concern me that
that we start building something that
may have to be adapted once Southern
water have done this more detailed study
surely the detailed study should be done
and then and then the the application
looked at to see if
those those possible necessary changes
can be put into that
because I'm assuming any adaptations
will be to do with reducing the amount
of water so is the gray water harvest in
already in these dwellings have we got
internal issue you know low flush
toilets and some of those issue issues
will be to do with how water is taken
away from the site now that's all
Underground
so I I'm a bit you know maybe maybe I'm
not a developer and I'm not an engineer
but I I can't get my head around we
already have capacity issue we're going
to allow a bill to go ahead and drains
be put in before we actually get a
detailed uh assessment and survey from
Southern water who already admit there
are capacity issues
the officer comes straight back in
um so any network reinforcement excuse
me any network reinforcement works is
obviously going to be off-site because
obviously there's no drainage across the
side at the moment and to your point in
terms of the the timing or the
assessment that's done this is something
that we talked about previously about
what's required by different bits of
legislation in terms of the water
industry act as mentioned planning
obviously can try and facilitate and
make sure there is capacity for the new
dwellings that are going in but
fundamentally the actual agreement to
connect to the existing file drainage
Network and indeed the capacity of that
network is something that is covered by
the separate legislation when the
agreement needs to be sought by the
developer with Southern water now
obviously part of the work that's done
on the local plan for all strategic
allocations including this application
or this site when it when it came
through was obviously as Adrian
mentioned in the training consultation
with Southern water about capacity and
planning for this number of houses over
that period of time but it is understood
that with every site as it comes forward
there is going to need to be very
specific work that's carried out but
that is governed primarily by the water
infrastructure act and not by
consideration that we make now we do
have some control I think it's really
important that as I say the grampian
conditions that we put on the you know
you can't you can't actually develop the
site you can't actually build anything
until we've agreed the method of
drainage for foul water so to your point
about
um actually the the principles behind
what they're going to do of which we
obviously do Southern water asks that
condition and we therefore if we need to
we would go back to them on that they do
need to agree that with us up front but
as mentioned Southern water won't allow
them to occupy certain dwellings and
indeed there's obviously more technical
aspects the building regs as well look
at when they're connecting that would
need to basically mean that you cannot
obviously occupy those dwellings until
the issue is dealt with I appreciate we
we go into this era and it's obviously a
strategic concern uh that is something
that we know is is very important for
strategic allocations and just generally
in the district the important thing with
regards to this Reserve matters though
is that the actual principle of the
number of dwellings the capacity of the
network has been agreed at outline it's
been agreed that's why there's a
grampian condition on the outline and
not on the reserve matters so that is a
matter that was dealt with at the
outline application and would be dealing
at that stage rather than the detailed
layout that we're looking at this
evening
okay do I have anyone else who wants to
speak
in that case we'll now put the motion
for the officer officer's recommendation
for approval to the vote those in favor
and those against
and any abstentions
thank you so the motion is carried
moving on to the next item is the
recommet recycling center first off I
have speaking in favor of the
application Mr Tony Michael
do we have Mr Tony Michael here you have
three minutes please thank you madam
chair members officers thank you for
your time this evening we would also
like to thank Julian doors the case
officer for a usual fair and
professional work on the application as
well
the merits of this application are as
shown in the report it is recommended
for approval and I only wish to
summarize a few points from this report
the site is a long history of commercial
use dating back to 1963 this is 60 years
of such use reclamet have made all
applications as necessary over these
many years
all Kent highways requirements have been
agreed to and they have no objection to
this application environmental health
have no objection
The increased floor space of an
established business is supported by
policy from the report
no harm to The Wider Countryside
acceptable in principle given the
established use of the site
no harm in terms of overshadowing loss
of light Outlook overlooking to
Neighbors
only one complaint and this from a site
60 meters away and no harm a judge to
fall upon them therefore all acceptable
in regards to residential immunity
Kent highways have also confirmed a
negligible impact on the road Network by
this very small increase in office space
those were the Salient planning grounds
there was a complaint from the adjacent
neighbor at Nelson Park that are not
related to the application but my client
wished to respond to to these one was
smoke from burning my client wished to
say the operation of the site
and operation of the site the outside
permitted hours
to answer this my client says reclimit
does not employ the use of fire for
burning of any materials instead they
use specialized Machinery in this only
to maintain equipment this generates
minimal heat to minimal smoke
they're recommended here to stringent
guidelines they are highly regulated by
the environment agency health and safety
executive and many other agencies
their Machinery undergoes regular
maintenance and inspection to ensure
Optimum efficiency and compliance there
has never been a fire at replement
I've done one occasion where the council
attended you to complaint in regards to
a possible fire it was actually observed
that this was minor smoke generated from
cutting a broken bolt off a piece of
equipment this the council officer
observed there was no breach and
witnessed only essential maintenance
their operating hours they comply
strictly to and they regularly conduct
their own sound impact assessment which
is required by the environment agency
and this ensures compliance with their
operating hours and their noise levels
they operate under a magnifying glass
and they take this very seriously thank
you
thank you I will now ask the principal
planning officer to outline the report
yeah thank you chair
so this is yeah
sorry going the wrong way
this is the application site sorry I
keep
touching the mouse in the wrong position
this is the application site so we've
got woodchurch Road
um recommend
um there with its car storage
and car parking area to the front there
so this is a application site outlined
in red as normal and as has been
mentioned it's for the erection of first
floor extensions to two Office Buildings
to provide additional office floor space
okay
um so this is um looking at down
woodchurch Road
with reclament on your right hand side
there and just looking the other way
down woodchurch road again we've
recommend now on the left hand side you
can see their car park
the two Office Buildings have been
helpfully shown by the applicant as
office and office B so we'll have a look
at those with some photos of both those
Office Buildings
so this is office building A so you can
see
it sits here
and has a larger sort of Workshop
building behind it
that's enough of you of the the building
office building A
and another building
enough of you of it there as well
um
and this is actually looking further out
from woodchurch Road
um outside of the site so that's the
site boundary so office building A sits
it within the site here so you can see
it is not particularly visible from that
part of woodchurch road though you do
get views of it when you are at the
front of the site
um so now looking back towards Office
Building B
it's actually located this is looking
across the parking area of the site that
we saw and the building is in this
location here
so we're looking at the building here
this so this is Office Building B as
it's referred to in the application this
is a domestic residential property
outside the application site Hillside
um this is enough of you of Building B
and you can see Hillside behind it
and again this is looking from the front
of the site so this is Building B and
you can see Hillside adjacent there
this is actually a picture of Hillside
and you will note that there is a gap
between the application site so the
recommend site and building
so Office Building B would be over here
but there is a gap there between it
so as I say we've looked at the
photographs of the two buildings and the
general site so we'll just look at the
plans
as proposed so this is existing
parking plan so you can see there's
parking as we just saw there and some
parking adjacent to office building A
and this is the proposed
um
parking plan
so it's an increase of 10 parking spaces
to serve with the additional
um office space that would be created
and there's also a cycle store in this
location here which we're requested by
KCC highways when they looked at the
application and the amended plans were
provided by the applicants to provide
additional those 10 additional parking
spaces and the cycle store
so this is front elevation of office a
that we looked at as existing
this is the front elevation as proposed
it will be increased to a maximum height
of 6.5 meters
and the additional space that would be
created and where to look at the floor
plans in a moment would be 102 square
meters of additional floor space
um so just running through the upper
Renovations of this building this is
existing the side elevation of office a
and the proposed side elevation it's
rear elevation and the elevation is
proposed and we have the other existing
side
and proposed side so this is the ground
floor
of the building as it stands now you can
see the workshop here and this is the
actual office bit in this location here
so it stays broadly the same
at ground floor level here but obviously
the introduction of stairs and then this
is the additional floor space that's
created so as I said it's 102 additional
square meters within that building
so going back to Office Building B it
was the flat roof building that we saw
adjacent to Hillside so this is existing
front elevation
the proposed front elevation
its side elevation as existing
and it's proposed side elevation its
rear elevation
its proposed elevation of rear elevation
and in this one this is existing floor
plan as it stands now
and this is the ground floor that's
proposed as you can see we have a
staircase going up here
and that takes us up to the proposed
first floor and on that building it's an
additional 81 square meters of office
space created at first floor level and
it would have it retains its flat roof
as we've seen
but it has a maximum height of 5.8
meters
so as I've already mentioned there were
no concerns about traffic generation for
the additional floor space from KCC
highways
and they consider that's been negligible
and it would not have an impact on the
free flow of traffic movement in the
area
they did raise the concerns about
additional parking requirements and the
need for cycle storage which as I've
already mentioned have been provided by
the applicant
in terms of
living conditions there are is no impact
from on residential amenity from The
Works to
office a as we've seen it's on the edge
of the site and it it won't be
noticeable either from
outside the site other than from the
sort of actual real Frontage of the site
office B is next to
um Hillside which is as I've mentioned
is a domestic residential property
and but it is noted that Hillside is
actually
on land that is actually slightly higher
than the application site by
approximately one meter
um there is a close boarded fence of
approximately 4.4 meters high or along
the boundary between the two sites and
there are some trees along the site and
as we've already seen there is a a gap
between the actual
residential property and there's a sort
of garage outbuilding
um there in that location so given the
the Gap there The Limited height of 5.8
meters and the boundary treatment and
the angle between office B and Hillside
it is considered there would not be a
adverse impacts or significant adverse
impact on the residential amenity of
of the occupiers of that property to
cause a sense of enclosure loss of light
or and there would be no windows in that
elevation of the first floor of the
office building to cause overlooking so
the officer recommendation is for
approval thank you Jeff
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted can I have
that secondary police faster seconded
thank you
and who would like to speak
counselor Mata face just a one quick
question uh you tell us in the report
and you've said just know how high the
buildings would be but how high are the
buildings at the moment so how much
extra is being added to the two Office
Buildings please
foreign
yeah apologies I'll we'll have to check
that
okay okay in that case councilor Keane
looking at the plans and the impact I
mean reclamette is not our prettiest
development but I don't see any planning
reasons to refuse this okay
thank you
ready
just be we're with us we're working on
it
so the office B is uh 2.7 to 5.7
um so yeah it's obviously adding adding
the additional floor on top so it's the
sort of full height and
[Applause]
the extension to office a
oh okay only one second
so ah here we go
um so the existing part of office a
that's single story is uh sort of 2.5 to
Eaves but then the roof pitches up to
attach to the building which goes up to
a height of about 4.8 and then the what
would occur is effectively the existing
roof would just carry on with the
extension that existing roof currently
pitches to 6.5 and it's very Apex
yeah Heights
counselor Wing just a bit clarification
so that that residential property do we
have some sort of elevation that shows
the height of the building and are there
any windows on that sign that could
potentially Overlook that property
um I
don't exactly have an elevation that
there are no windows in the elevation of
either the flank elevation of the house
that faces onto it or the proposed
extension at first floor level that
faces onto it so
if that answers the question
anyone else
in that case
um I will move for the motion for the
officer's recommendation for approval to
the vote
those in favor
all right thank you the emotion is
carried
moving on to the next item land adjacent
to the cliff top North fourland Avenue
broadstairs speaking against the
application is Theo Nicolo
thank you three minutes
thank you I'm here at presenting the
views and concerns of all eight
residents at redriff as as a resident of
the north Florida State I have a vested
interest to preserve the quality of the
estate in particular the issues of
biodiversity the environment and
potential over development of sites with
specific reference to the proposed eight
Bay garage and Annex block this
unreasonable and disproportionate
provision of parking for a we believe
this is a disproportionate provision of
parking for a four bed property we
highlight that the annex total internal
gross area is 292 square meters
is an additional 43.3 percent of the
extremely large
672 square meter area of the main house
the Annex in its current form would
therefore represent excessive over
development in terms of scale size and
in particular location
we'd also like to draw the council's
attention to the following local local
plans and government legislation which
has clearly not been adhered to these
are broadstairs in Saint Peter's
neighborhood development plan 2018 and
to 2031
also thanet District adopted local plan
2020 quality development
furthermore the national planning policy
framework states that the local planning
authorities should consider policies to
resist inappropriate development of
residential Gardens within Diva within
where developments would cause harm to
the local area
furthermore in Thana residential Gardens
are also formed part of thanet's green
infrastructure providing biodiversity
and wildlife habitats
also consideration to the Town and
Country planning act 1990 and the new
legislation regarding biodiversity Net
game set at 10 also we have concerns
regarding implied backline developments
where sites may be over developed to the
rear of plots
the rear development is excessively
overbearing in height
we cannot ascertain from the proposals
the construction ground floor datum
there is also no reference to
topographical survey
this application is has is a significant
overbearing impact and it's based on
over development of the site scale and
height of the annex proximity and
Boundary to and overlooking issues
increased noise and disturbance from
that will be generated from the garages
blocking of lights on to redriff and
finally the clear lack of adherence to
local Council guidance in our
submissions we have proposed some
solutions to these concerns
we conclude that the proposed Annex for
a disabled person would from a health
and safety perspective be more
appropriate as a ground level Annex
without a stair access I would also
finally like to share with you that I
have been advised that is is the
intention of the applicant to Market
this plot for sale with planning I would
therefore ask the committee to seriously
reconsider the to consider the reason
for this application thank you chair
thank you I will now hand over to the
principal planning officer to outline
the report
thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red
you have Cliff or Menard running north
to south here on the right hand side and
this is not Fallen Avenue
so this is an aerial photo
so here we have Cliff Promenade North
Portland Avenue here and this is the
application site in this location here
um this is a 3D View
it's really to give members an idea of
how the land levels sort of slope down
and North Fallen Avenue is along here
and it's at a higher level
um than Cliff Promenade and this is
redriff um redriff apartment block
that's been mentioned
um by the speaker just a moment ago and
hopefully members can see that it is at
a higher level and then you have the
garden coming out
and that's actually Terrace and you can
see a series of sort of levels where the
land drops down and you can see if you
look at the buildings that's north
um yeah North Fallen Grange is at a much
lower level as are the other buildings
on Cliff Promenade
so we've got some photographs of the
site so we're in Cliff Promenade this is
North fall and Grange which we saw
in the photograph of the aerial image
earlier
and the application of society is on the
right hand side here
this is looking the alpha way
so we're still in Cliff Promenade
that's the edge of redriff apartment
block on the left here and you can see
some vacant sites here that the
properties and hopefully you can members
can make out that the land level here is
lower than the level at the top there
without North Avenue where those
properties face
so again we're looking still in Cliff
Promenade looking towards
apologies I've forgotten name of that
house but we're looking
um further down
away from the site so the site would
behind the car and on the left hand side
there but you can see the distance of
Cliff Promenade and the cliff as well
there
and again this is a view looking onto
the application site
over the fence of the gate there and
hopefully members can make out there's
some sort of terracing and changes in
land level up to redriff at the higher
level there
and again this is a wider view of the
similar that we've just seen so that's
Red Roof here the application site and
some of the vacant plots that haven't
been built out
in this location here
this is existing site plan
and
so this is the application site it does
have actual um levels
um set out on the site on that plan but
I appreciate members will not be able to
see them but there were Wars
topographical information submitted with
the application when it was submitted to
us so we can understand the levels of
where things are proposed so this is
redriff in the location here
um this is the plot to the South has
um had consent for an app dwelling on
the site
um
and there is actually a current
application for a dwelling on the site
now that is actually under consideration
um but looking at the application site
it is not considered that there would be
an issue of that coming forward for
development
so if members were to Grant this
application on this plot here it would
not
um prohibit this application that we've
got also being allowed
the plot to the north which is shown
here as plot seven if members can read
that refers to an old outline
application which now and Reserve
matters
um was granted some time ago in 2019 for
a dwelling on that site that um a
reserve matters application has now
expired but again it is fought by
officers that the
the developmental of the application the
dwelling and the annex on this site as
proposed would not prohibit
the adjoining sites coming forward and
being developed if applications were
submitted but obviously they would have
to work around any
approval on this site
so this is a proposed site plan
so Cliff Promenade is here we have the
main house setback in this location here
and it's actually set back some 15
meters from the front of the application
site it's approximately 1.8 meters at
its closest point to the southern plot
that's the plot to the South
and I think it's six meters to the
boundary of the plot two
the north there and the annex sits to
the rear here
the main house itself would be about 15
meters
from the rear of the application site
but it is appreciated that the annex
obviously is much closer to the rear of
the site being just over a meter or so
from that
so again just to refresh members
memories so we're looking at the site
here this is a site as I said we have
the current application on but it's the
adjoining site for a dwelling in this
location here
um but just to refresh members that this
is the rear of the red riff apartment
site as you can see the bed uh the
building actually steps down
there right is um a flat here
and it
enzyme will point out to members that
this application we're considering
tonight has had a previous consent
um in 2019 for the exact same
development with the annex and the
dwelling as proposed
it's being resubmitted because they did
not commence Works within the free years
that were granted but it was um
submitted at the same time that redriff
was granted consent
um redriff was granted consent actually
in two phases
it was granted consent initially for
seven dwellings it then came in for some
underground parking and then there was a
subsequent application to add the unit
hit that you see here to make the whole
development eight units so that's the
single unit that was added on at a later
stage so
[Music]
um it when the original application was
granted in 2019 for the dwelling on this
site with its Annex
um redriff was already
um granted consent obviously it wasn't
built out or completed at that stage and
what certainly wasn't occupied but
consideration was given when
um permission was granted for the
dwelling of the annex on the site we're
considering tonight
of the impact on redriff
so this is actually the proposed
um front facing so he's facing
elevation of the house so this is what
you would see from
Cliff Promenade obviously it set further
back so it wouldn't be
um as noticeable so you see it here
this is the west facing elevation so the
rear elevation
and this is a north-facing elevation
so that's the one facing the plot that
had the consent but that has now expired
this is the plot facing onto the South
so this would face onto the side that we
have the current application on
and this is the annex so this is the
east facing part of the annex so this
would face onto the house
and as has been mentioned it's a
two-story Annex essentially with the
annex being on the Upper Floor and we'll
look at the floor plans
in a little while but it does have a
series of garages which would
accommodate approximately eight cars
um
it as I understand it from the
applicants and their agents he is a
collector of cars so it's not for any
business purposes or anything like that
he just wants to store his cars in a
secure building
um so it would not be used for business
purposes as I've mentioned it would be
just to accommodate his private vehicles
and and I'm
I'm not aware that there is a issue if
you have space that you have a limit of
how many vehicles you could keep for
domestic purposes
if they are purely for that purpose
but so looking at the North facing
um elevation of the annex
this is the west facing Annex so this
would be the view that properties in
North fall and Avenue particularly
redriff people in the Red River
Apartments would get of the application
of the annex so it is essentially
a blank elevation with some high level
um Windows here and that's the staircase
concerns have been raised about the
height of the building as we've heard
but also the potential for overlooking
um when people are using the staircase
it's not considered I'll go back to the
changes and levels and things that are
in a moment but just to
touch on the bases that we do not
consider there would be overlooking from
people coming going from the
um
using the stairs and the entrance to the
annex because it would be just precisely
for that there's not enough room for
sitting out there
and they would be using and enjoying the
garden of the main house because it is
an additional accommodation an
incidental not a separate dwelling
so we do not have concerns that there
would be overlooking or
a sense of overlooking from people just
using the staircase to enter and access
the annex so that's the proposed
self-facing elevation so you can see the
staircase in more detail and you can see
it really is just a staircase to get up
and into and out of the annex
so this is actual ground floor of the
property so you can see you've got the
main sort of living accommodation of the
house in this area here and then you've
got some
a gym and swimming pool and plant room
and various sort of
um accommodation like that there but the
main living space is here
this is the annex and as you can see as
I've mentioned before it is garage
spaces at the ground floor level
um so this is the Upper Floor
so as you can see the sort of the main
house sits here as with the bedrooms and
the Upper Floor accommodation
this is basically storage at this level
and in the annex it would have two
bedrooms ensuite
um it and
obviously is Kitchen a living room at
this end
so this is a North facing section
through the site
and you as you can see that we're
looking from Cliff Promenade over on the
left-hand side of the slide
the land levels rise up a little and
then level off with the house
and the annex and what the applicants
are proposing to do
is actually drop down
um the back end of the application site
to the same level as the main bit of the
house the site where the house would be
built
and this was proposed on the application
that was approved
and we're looking again at the south
facing elevation so again you can see
that that level would be consistent
so in terms of
and this is a site section that's a
been drawn up to show the difference
between redriff Apartments here that's
the lower level
unit we looked at that was added on
but again approved at a similar time as
the original version of this application
was approved
so you can see it drops down so
essentially what you would have
is as I say the the line level sloping
from North Portland Avenue which should
be over here down to Cliff Promenade
so with the Red Roof Apartments sit
approximately 28 meters above sea level
at its highest point so this this is its
sort of Frontage with North Island
Avenue
um the rear of the and it's just over 23
meters above sea level at its boundary
with the application sites are in this
location here
um it's the rear of the elevation the
proposanics would sit within two meters
of the boundary of the rear boundary of
Red Roof Apartments but that's
the actual Garden area not obviously not
the block itself
um
but they are as I've said they are
proposing to reduce the land levels down
so
it drops down to the same level of where
the houses
are so given this reduction and the fact
that the rear elevation of Red River
Apartments is set some 15 meters away
from the rear boundary
it's not considered that the propos
annex would be overbearing or result in
loss of light
or sense of enclosure to that
development it is acknowledged that
there may be some loss of use
particularly potentially from this
apartment here
from to the sea but that would be loss
of views rather than a sense of
enclosure or
um actual harmful residential amenities
and the loss of use is not a planning
consideration in the same way as
overlooking or sense of enclosure or
loss of light so we do feel that there
would be except an acceptable
relationship between
the proposed development including the
annex and the occupiers of redriff that
it would not be um
sufficient to result in a reason for
refusal
so just um to conclude members
there is no Highway impact
the design of the dwelling
is striking and unusual but
it's felt that North Fallen Avenue is
the place to go a bit unique and a bit
different and it does still use
materials that are found in the local
area and on the estate so it is thought
to be acceptable
um
sorry they have paid the Sam put in the
undertaking for the Sam contribution so
the officer recommendation is for
approval members thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted can the vice
chair please second
thank you do I have anyone who wants to
speak councilman law
yes thank you chair
um so can you just confirm to a couple
of points to be pleased the first one
was uh the original planning expired and
that's why it's being renewed and
secondly the annex was an addition to
the new proposal
or the existing proposal thank you
correct in it was granted originally
planning consent it's in the
quite a lengthy sectional planning
history because I tried to sort of deal
with the surrounding developments as
well it was granted consent in 2019 the
same application we're considering now
so the dwelling and the annex and the
said the schemas before us now was
granting consent in 2019 it's come back
with the free year normal you've got to
implement it within that time period of
three years it wasn't implemented within
that time so they've sought to resubmit
and the annex was yeah could I come back
so if if this was refused for example
then when it was previously passed then
the likelihood it would go to appeal and
if so that would cost potentially cost
us money if successful
yes they could well appeal if we were to
refuse it today yes
um but obviously I can't speak to the
applicant's intentions
councilor open
thank you chair yeah um
question
um was the site ever previously
developed was there a house building on
the site it looks like there might have
been
um I don't know if you know that or not
was it okay we'll have none of that here
uh so yeah there was a there was a there
was a Convent on the site for those of
you that have been around a while you
may recall the a large application came
in for originally 13 and then 12 houses
for the development of this area and
also other areas in the north from the
state which committee refused but then
was approved on appeal which then result
in lots of individual Reserve Mass
applications to sort of set the
principle of developing the site at that
point okay
um
as as has been said by councilor more
you know we this we the council will
prove this same development in 2019
therefore we can't refuse it now but
you'll just be stupid too and we will
end up at a pill and we and we will get
costs against so uh
that's what I want to say thank you
sorry
I was just waiting sorry to jump in
before
um so yeah I just wanted to confirm so I
think it's just important to stress that
the proposal is identical
circumstances are are not different in
terms of the timing of when redriff was
granted consent which therefore is
committed development so then obviously
any subsequent decision that was made is
made in the line that redriff's been
approved just to just absolutely point
out a difference
um that obviously when it was approved
previously it was under the old local
plan and not under the new local plan in
2020 however we don't consider that
there's a policy change in terms of the
quality of development in terms of one
of the changes that did occur which is
relevant and addressed in the report is
that broadstairs neighborhood plan has
subsequently been adopted that includes
the area of high townscape value policy
that was in the old local plan that is
not in the new local plan so effectively
it's the same it's the same policy basis
to which both decisions are made but
there is a slight difference between the
policy framework which is addressed in
the report
aware that the before I bring in Council
of my to face I'm just aware that the
gentleman who spoke from redriff at the
beginning would like to speak again and
so I'm not able to bring you back in
under the policies and the procedures of
the committee I'm sorry
um councilor Mata face I was just going
to say CM will remember when it came
forward in 20
12 and it was refused on the grounds of
correctly if I'm wrong it was a very
important habitat for certain moths yeah
um but I do remember I've asked you this
before I talked about section 106 money
when it was the whole site was up for
approval so presumably that does that
still apply
um so if there were some applications
that came forward as part of the reserve
matters application so to the to the
outline but what also happened is the
individual plots were sold off and then
bought by individuals so when they
developed their sites they weren't
effectively on the hook for the 106 on
the original because they were different
applications what we did do for those
that were developed we have received
section 106 contributions towards
affordable housing because that was one
of the things that was put forward in
terms of making sure that came in but
that didn't apply to all 12 plots
because all 12 plots for one hadn't been
developed and they weren't developed
under that original application
thank you Council Robin
yeah sorry to come back but I just that
um Mr Livingston come in with
information after I spoke and then it
went on but I think what's important in
within the report is that both
broadstairs Town Council and the
broadstairs society do not have a
problem or an issue with this
thank you
[Music]
okay if I don't have any more speakers
then we will now put the motion for the
officer's recommendation for approval to
the vote
um those in favor
thank you that's carried
so the next item is uh 32 Pro Hill
broadstairs speaking in favor of the
application is Mr Lewis Duggan you have
three minutes
thank you chair
the proposed plans designed by myself my
partner who feel dad's the architect
have also been passed by John Eldridge
playing a consultancy prior to being
submitted and he is confident we are not
reaching any planning laws I've based
our speech as advised to address the
objections in the report if you have the
report in front of you it may help to
follow down the objections which are
bullet pointed so you know which
objection I'm referring to firstly the
first objection is related to the party
War act which I understand is not a
planet matter and that will be addressed
accordingly the next objections State
four rooms will have never negative
impact on loss of Light which is
strictly not true Rosemary Boulevard has
been into number 34 and only only deemed
one room which is currently used as a
study to be impacted slightly by the
extension proposed and as it is a study
it's currently not used as a habitable
room this also does not affect light
enough according to Rosemary which is
she does state in her report is also
noted that the rear of number 34 has
additions to the original footprint we
are proposing to come out just shy from
the line of their property as you'll be
able to see in the street plan we both
have Side Access of approximately three
feet so we're not putting an extension
up directly in front of the study window
the next three bullet points all relate
to what I've just said overshadowing has
also been mentioned which is not the
case we have North facing garden and the
sunlight that gets into the study window
comes from the front of the property our
permitted development rights allow us to
build a two-story extension and match
existing height of the roof which we did
not want to do because this will have
more impact on the neighbors instead we
have considered them during the planning
and design process and put a flat roof
on the proposed extension the window is
in question on the seventh bullet point
is going to be a Velux window in the
roof which is over a bath so the window
is not going to reach any privacy to the
neighbors number nine states the
measuring function can't be used
actually on on the council website which
is which is not our fault we have the
designs are to scale so it can be
measured that way number 30 wanted to
gauge how high the extension is going to
be it's going to be 0.8 meters higher
than the rear extension that's already
on there which is roughly three meters
down from the existing Bungalow all
windows and Velux windows will be
installed according to building control
specifications so no overlooking will be
able to have them also number 30 wants
restrictions on any Windows going down
the side of our property if we wanted
additional Windows there there we would
go through planning we wouldn't do
anything we're not allowed to do
the driveway which is of concern to
number 30 will also also will be
installed with a repairable blocks no
water will drain into his property and
the reason for the additional drive
around the front is because I'm a
builder with two Vans my plant has a car
so more spaces are needed also we want
to Future proof the house for when we
have a family one day to keep more cars
off the road
lastly Jill bayford's reason reasons for
bringing this to committee are loss of
light highway safety which I've just
addressed and also the concern for
character character is one of the main
reasons we bought the Bungalow and the
rear extension will not be seen from the
front street view at all however
permitted development will change the
front view as you will see the roof
which is why we have put in what we have
the only thing that's changing on the
front is the driveway which keeps keeps
in with most properties on Crow Hill as
mentioned in Rosemary's report thank you
for listening and we hope answering the
objections will Aid you in following the
planet planning officer's recommendation
of approval thank you
thank you speaking against the
application Ms Steffi Egan
and I'll just remind you three minutes
yeah
um
in the
um response to the to my objections it's
actually riddled with inaccuracies and
unfortunately I can only
have time for one and I'd like to draw
attention to page 114 second paragraph
where the agent for Mr Duggan who's also
the architect for this is claiming that
whilst there may be some loss of light
it may not an architect you should be
able to prove how much light I'm going
to lose
and Outlook from existing Windows facing
the site is considered the impact would
not be so good significantly greater
given the existing relationship of the
application site to neighboring windows
and that is wrong if you look at the con
plan the window in question and whether
I'm using it as a study as a laundry
room or whatever I may have to use this
as a future bedroom very soon
it is facing 32 kohale and is facing
Southeast and if you if any of the
council has had a chance to have a look
at my additional evidence which
hopefully you might have seen in the
meeting room and thank you if you did
the position the property my deed goes
back to 1912 The Bungalow was built
later and what has been taken into
conserv consideration was the
prescription Act of 1832 under Section 3
which is gives grants my because my
property had ever since the Bungalow and
my house was built uninterrupted light
coming into that room
and what's that it's not like
legislation you need to take into
consideration for planning you have
anything after the building regulations
comes in from the center point of that
window
is a 45 degree angle of light coming
into that room actually giving me
uninterrupted sunlight for at least half
a year until midday and not just the
early morning
they're going to reduce this angle to 12
degrees of direct light coming into the
room now also if you ever saw the
Bungalow you would have wondered why is
the roof the size of this because it
gives my property to the center of the
window at 25 degree angle of
overshadowing that would be
significantly increased the entire
length of my property
so therefore I'm claiming that this
development has significant loss of
light for me and therefore loss of
Outlook and therefore creating adverse
overbearing and creating an adverse
overbearing effect creating an
oppressive living environment for
existing and future residents yes in
that one room
what is overbearing it's not
quantifiable
but
you don't have to take my word for it I
did the measurements I submitted to you
last last minute I know some diagrams
please at least reject this proposal and
have a site visit so you can see for
yourself what the impact of that
extension will be to my property thank
you
thank you I will now hand over to the
principal planning officer to outline
the report
thank you chair
um this is the application site outlined
in red here number 32 Crow Hill
um so Crow Hill you can see is here
Linden Avenue
um is to the rear of the site so this is
an aerial view of the property so number
32 is in the location here
and you can see another view of it here
so it's a shadow style Bungalow with
some accommodation already at first
floor level and you can see there's an
existing rear projection into the garden
um and there's some small extensions
um next to that this is uh the property
of
um the um speak the speaker that's just
spoken so this is the existing Windows
within her side elevation so there's one
at first for a level and two or three at
ground floor levels you can see the
existing ones at ground floor level here
and there's another one in this location
here which you'll see later on in the
photographs
and this is the front of the property so
um you can see that some excavation
Works have already been carried out to
the front so the demolition of the front
boundary wall wouldn't require
permission because it's not in a
conservation area but the excavation
Works
um will require consent um and they're
proposing to use this space for for
parking provision for for vehicles and
you can see the existing access to the
side of the property so the site runs up
to the boundary on the right hand side
here and you can see the fence on the
left hand side here and you can see
within the existing front elevation
there's an existing Dormer at First full
level and you'll see later on the
proposal is to change that window to
French doors
so this is looking to the left hand side
so this is um number 34 Crow Hill you
can see two story properties in a row of
terraces and then to the right hand side
number 30 Crow Hill which is also a
bungalow with accommodation first floor
level
and then this is a view from the rear of
the application property
and this is also from the rear so this
is the application property on the right
hand side so you can say this is a
existing extension that projects out so
the proposal is to extend on the right
hand side up to that same rear
renovation so it won't project any
further than this rearrivation that you
can see and then you can see the
properties in Linden Avenue Beyond
and then another view from above so
again you can see the existing rear
projections The Proposal is to sort of
mimic that with a projection that comes
out on the right hand side here to the
same depth with the same
um matching height although the height
is increasing which you'll see in the
plans and then the infilling of the
space in between
um again so the whole thing is squared
off to create a single story extension
that squares it off in line with the
existing rear and side elevations of the
building
and so now we're going to walk around
the side elevation so again as you heard
the concerns were to do with the impacts
on this neighboring property so we're
going to walk around the side here you
can see the the neighbors windows so
this is taking on that side for you so
this is the neighboring window
um that um has raised concerns and you
can see there's a window first of all
level above and then some
um Windows Beyond and then this is the
application property on the right hand
side here so there's a gap of 1.8 meters
from the neighboring elevation to the
existing elevation of the existing
property and that Gap will be maintained
through the with the extension being
added on so a 1.8 meter Gap will
continue with the rear extension has
been added
and then this is taken inside the
neighboring property looking towards the
application property so this is the
existing
um site elevation of the neighbor and
you can see that this window does look
partially onto their existing side wall
um so some of the concerns when
addressed within the report is that
there's already some loss of light and
Outlook already to this window from the
fact it is facing onto the side
elevation of the existing property
um but you can see the the concern
raised by the neighbor is that there's
light and Outlook at an angle from this
window so standing off to the right hand
side here you would she would get some
light and Outlook at this point here and
the extension is looking to extend into
this space
so this again just another view from
that window looking towards the um
neighbor's uh sorry the application
property and the extension is going in
this location here
and then this is now in the rear Garden
of the neighbor so again the neighboring
window is is here and you can see here
these are secondary windows I believe
because the further to the rear so it's
mainly this window that's raising the
concern
um at first or level there's an existing
window but that's looking onto the
existing roof of the applicant and this
roof isn't changing in in height
so again the app The Proposal is to
extend into this location here
and then this now is looking back onto
number 30
um there's a gap of 3.5 meters to um
this neighboring property and
um
it's not considered there is we've got a
large gap there so this is now the block
plan showing the extension so
whilst it's all colored um this bit
actually is existing and then it's
squaring off in this location here so
looking at the elevations this is the
proposed front elevation with the
existing Dormer window and you can see
with the original front boundary wall
and
um and now that's showing that that area
excavated and the Dormer changed into
doors so this actually isn't enlarging
um what's actually happening is just the
um seal is being dropped down so it's
not becoming a larger Dormer if you were
looking from a side view it's just the
fact that that's dropping down so that's
actually inside the roof slope with a
glazed batter strading area
and this is now the side facing the
neighbor with concerns so these are the
existing Windows within that side
elevation and you can see the existing
rear projections
and this is the proposed so the main
roof is remaining as existing
um the change is the the addition of
this projection so it's um five point
it's five meters deep and it will be 5.5
meters to Ridgeline level at that point
there but you can see it's following
through from the existing Eaves
and then you can see there's two vdux
windows within the existing roof these
are serving
um bathrooms and again they face onto
the blank side elevation of the neighbor
so there's no concerns with the
provision of these windows in the roof
space and on this side view you can also
see that front Dormer as well so again
you can see that the dorm is not
enlarging it's just the fact that
they're digging down into the roof space
and then the balcony is being provided
or the balcony area has been provided in
the roof space
and then this is the other side
Innovation facing number 30 as existing
and as proposed so again the only
increase there is that a slight increase
in Ridge height of 0.8 meters of this
existing extension but the actual depth
of the extension remains as existing and
similarly the v-loss windows were faced
onto the existing roof slopes of the
neighbor so again no overlooking
concerns of these and they also again
serve bathroom and wardrobe areas so
unlikely to be obscure glazed
and then this is the existing rear
renovation
and this is the proposed so you can see
the applicant has attempted to keep the
height of the rear extension down so
this is a flat roof area at the back so
again this is the on the right hand side
is the neighbor's window that's raising
concern and you can see that it's
keeping the same eave level and pitching
away from the boundary up to this um
flat roof area
um in terms of the additional Windows
there's a v Lux within that rear
elevation that's just facing the garden
of three Skylight Windows within the
flat roof and then bifold doors with a
balcony within that reiteration again
facing into the existing Garden
so ground ground floor plans this is
existing ground floor plants on the
bottom left-hand side is the existing
rear projection and then you can see
that there's where it's squaring off at
Ground full level with a neighboring
window being in this location here at
ground floor level
and then this is the existing proposed
existing first of all plan
and this is the proposed with the
bedroom being added at the rear with the
bifold doors and you can see to the
front that's where the French doors are
being added to the existing Dormer and
the balcony
and sorry also here you can see the
Velux window so the Velux windows are
serving these bathroom areas so there's
two in this location here one in this
location here and one here which appears
to be
um a wardrobe walking wardrobe area
and then roof wise this is the existing
roof plan and this is the proposed you
could get into the flat roof element in
between and the two areas pitching away
from the neighbors
so the microphones are the impact on the
character of the area so in terms of the
actual
um front elevation
the only change is the um the windows to
the doors
as you saw from the photos there's a
variety of different styles of property
within the road it's not considered that
the change from a window window to a
door would result in any any significant
visual impact from the from the area so
this uh the impact from this this is
considered to be acceptable in terms of
the actual excavation works again
there's a number of properties that have
parking in the area as I mentioned
there's no it's not a conservation area
so the provision of this space is
considered to be acceptable they're
proposing to pave it so there would be
drainage permeable Paving and highways
have raised I've not commented because
of it being a smaller householder
application but there would be
visibility sprays from this space and
therefore the impact on highways from
the provision of this for parking is
considered to be acceptable
um and then in terms of the impacts on
Neighbors which is is really the main
um consideration from from the
neighbor's point of view
um
as you as you see from the sorry going
back to the side elevation so the side
elevation that's facing the neighbor
there will be an impact to the lighting
outlooks to this neighbor's neighbor's
window
um but as you saw from the the photos
they there is already some impact
because the fact there is the existing
building in this location
um it's very difficult to protect
um light and Outlet to side facing
Windows because there's lots of PD
rights that properties have they could
build erect fences up to two meters on
the boundary and they could build a four
meter deep extension to the rear without
any planning permission so they could
already build that not necessarily
what's proposed because it's too high
but they could build a four meter deep
extension without planning permission
being required and therefore it's very
difficult for us to try and refuse an
application on the grounds that we
consider an impact to a side facing
window to be um significant when there
are those fallbacks
um that exist
um so given the fact that the applicant
has has attempted to reduce the impact
as much as possible by keeping the ridge
height down as low as possible following
the ease line and not bringing it any
closer to the neighbor and given the
fact that there's already some partial
loss of Outlook and light anyway from
this window is considered on balance the
impact is acceptable
so in terms of the other neighbor as you
saw from the plans there's the slight
increase
um in height of of this by 0.8 meters
given that distance it's not going to
impact any rear windows of this property
so the impact on that neighbors
considered to be acceptable and in terms
of to the rear there's a distance of 25
meters from the proposed bifolding doors
to the rear Garden of the property in
Linden Road so again there's no privacy
concerns regarding regarding that so
overall it's recommended for approval
thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted can the vice
chair please second
Ed
thank you and uh councilor Mata face
first please
um if I could assess Emma there's a
Juliet Balcony at the back as well
looking um it's mentioned it's there is
there any concern about overlooking into
Linden Avenue because it is actually
very close to Linden Avenue a new
original map it's wonderful there been
any concern raised there about
overlooking
um but there's a distance of the 25
meters
um I believe from from the rear
elevation to the boundary
um I believe also that Linda lavier
thinks a high ground level I think from
visiting the site so
um given the distance and the change in
level we've not had any objections as
far as I'm concerned from the residents
in that location
um so yeah I think we consider the
impact acceptable
before I bring you in counselor Botha
can I just ask you to use a different
microphone we have a minor technical
problem with
um that one that you were using earlier
thank you I'm gonna have to ask um
do the same if you speak again in the
meeting
thank you chair
um I I called this in because In
fairness really to to the residents of
the area
lots of light is a consideration I'm
concerned about the possible
inaccuracy of the measurements
um
and I totally agree with our lady
speaker that the
should be able to use her rooms however
she wants to however they used it
currently
um I have to say I think if ever there
are a cause for a site visit this is one
because I think we need to see properly
how this would be affected and I really
think that would be beneficial thank you
councilman
yes thank you chair I was wondering if
Emma and Ian could explain the rest of
the members of the committee uh the 45
degree Rule and in in reference to the
fact that the object was mentioned that
that 45 degree always been affected and
she's only got 12 degrees now just so
that everyone's aware and I also agree
that that might might require that we
actually
um have a site visit thank you
and the 40
45 rule that we usually look at is more
to rear windows
um so if you're extending out and the
neighbor had a rear window then we'd
look at the 45 degree line from that
window coming out from side windows it's
very difficult because the the extension
already hits 45 degree lines from her I
think what she mentioned mentioned in
Her speech is that she has light coming
in at a 45 degree angle into that room
um but because it's a because it's a
side facing window it's very difficult
for us to
um really protect the light from that's
why facing window even though it's a
habitable room we accept it is a
habitable room because she's using it as
a study
um but it's very difficult like I
mentioned because of the fallback for PD
that could impact on that anyway but I
think yeah if members feel their site
visit would be useful then that is
certainly something we could consider
uh and just to come back on a sort of
distinction between loss of Light which
is a material Prime consideration and
the right to light obviously the right
to light as as mentioned by the speaker
is a sort of separately defined legal
easement over land which is governed by
civil legislations
Etc but the Judgment for members is is
yeah whether or not there is a loss of
light that occurs as a result of this
that harms the living conditions
obviously in our in our view because the
fact that the roof hips away uh and the
distance isn't changed of how close the
property is you know not you know taking
into account again the the use of that
room is why we've considered it
acceptable but just to clarify that
there is a sort of Distinction there and
we have had instances before and again
sort of slightly harking back but the
site in Minster which had a lot of
controversy in a site visit where
members approved the development but
they could never build it because there
was an injunction or similar sort of
civil proceedings taken out because of a
right to light over a side window
specific so there's a separate element
there
thank you councilor Garner
thank you using a different more
appropriate microphone
um
good
um I've just had a couple of questions
firstly I agree with councilor bayford
on
more or less everything she said and
we I certainly believe we could we would
benefit from a side visit here so I am
minded to um vote to refuse this
application to enable that to happen
um I would like a little bit of
clarification about
um
about permitted development and what
could happen
if we do
um if we do refuse this or what what
they could do because I did read with
with interest the email I will received
I think from um Mr dad's about which
sort of outlined the course of action
that might be taken if we were to
deign to refuse permission for this so I
would like a bit of clarification on why
in fact this we are having this
application what what is the difference
please what why why do we need it
I think we're just waiting for an
officer to come back in just bear with
us a moment
um so previously development rights for
detached units uh detached to weddings
they can build out four meters from the
original rear renovation but there's a
restriction on height so at the moment
this is proposing a 5.5 meter high
extension and that's too high so this
couldn't be built under permitted
development
um but from I believe it's four meters
just double checking because there is a
restriction where if you're two meters
from the boundary it changes but just
can't remember
yeah I believe it's four meters in
height so if it was dropped down one and
a half meters
um this is also five meter deep
extension so basically this is too deep
and Too Tall if it was reduced from five
meters down to four meters in depth and
if it was reduced from 5.5 meters in
height down to four meters in height
then it would be permitted development
okay thank you very much councilor wing
interestingly the original design of the
house put that that the the the the the
extra bit going out on the side of the
house where there was a driveway so the
original consideration of the design of
the house would have been to have put a
driveway between that that bit that
stuck out and The Neighbor Next Door so
what we're proposing here is is to
actually
create do that in effect
but it does seem to me that it's way too
close to that the boundary of the of the
house on the other side which doesn't
benefit from a driveway being in the way
so I will just support we refuse this
application and we need a site visit
because I can't whatever way you look at
it from there it seems as if this
development will result in a in a
raising in a lifting of the wall and
then a roof that I grant goes away from
the property but will still have quite a
devastating impact looking at these
plans uh on that on the light into that
room but I'd like to personally have a
look
anyone else
um
oh yeah I'm going to bring the officer
back in
so just just to confirm where we are in
terms of a number of people have
expressed a wish for to visit the site
we haven't haven't quite hit the uh the
magic number in terms of the majority of
members just to confirm and the motion
on the table is to approve and just to
be clear you're voting about that motion
you're voting to refuse the application
it's just that that motion would fall
and then obviously if anyone wanted to
propose an alternative motion at that
point then they could do so
okay if I don't have any more speakers
then um we will put the motion to
um for the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote and if you want a
site visit you need to vote against
um that's the only way so uh can I have
those in a favor
and those against
the motion is lost
in that case we need an alternative
motion would someone like to make a
proposal councilor bayford
thank you chair I'd like to propose a
site thank you and the second second uh
I got councilor Garner's hand first
so uh just a reminder from the beginning
of the meeting the visit site visit will
take place on the 7th of July
sorry oh I'm just being corrected here
we just need to vote on the motion for
the site visit please
all those in favor
[Music]
anyone against
okay
it will be a site visit that is that
one's carried
um
it's on the 7th of July and it will be
at 9 30 in the morning
thank you
now I'm conscious at this point that
councilor roseki left the meeting
um at the beginning of this item I don't
know where he is but perhaps we could
just take a moment we can get him back
in thank you
yeah if if we just um take a five minute
Comfort break while we find Council oh
counselor Ozaki if anyone wants it
I think I think
yeah we just we just take five minutes
thank you
can we can we reform please
counselor about to face
[Laughter]
all right thank you very much
um
so next item on the agenda is land north
of down Barton Road Saint Nicholas at
Wade and I have first speaking in favor
of the application Mr Dean Richards
you have three minutes
good evening
I'm Mr Richards and this is my wife and
son Sarah and George Sarah and George
members of the planning committee
approve the house next door and stated
at the committee it was a sustainable
location
the permission was granted for the
glamping development around my property
and when it was built higher than it
should have been it was approved
retrospectively
then it does not have enough housing
Supply despite what he said in the
report the council has not met its duty
to provide enough self bills in the
district
we have evidence to prove this
the house is larger than next door
development and so there will not be
landscape impacts
our land is very important to us as a
family we visit daily and often stay
weekends in our Shepherd's Hut
and have done so for the last several
years so we'll create no extra Village
traffic
a single story dwelling would be located
where our four shipping containers are
and therefore would have no impact on
wildlife
we have planted several trees since
owning our land and kept clean and tidy
and we used to live in Saint Nicholas
Village and fitted in with Village Life
and church
since having our land Mr Evans has built
his house his two barns his glamping
site
his log cabins surrounded us impacted on
our view
how can I have all that and me not be
able to self-build our family home
foreign
if we sold to Travelers they would be
allowed to live there which would have a
huge impact on Village Life
finally I'd like to thank councilor Pugh
and Sir Roger gal for their support
thank you
um councilor Pugh
thank you chair
um I called in this applications
committee because I think it's important
that not only do we have a variety of
housing in The Villages but one of the
main gripes I have and this is where I
suppose there's always the challenge
particularly with the local plan and uh
and and building on agricultural land as
has happened in in a lot of The Villages
is that there's there's there never
seems to be enough housing for people
that want to have grown up in the
village and want to stay and live in the
village and and then raise their
families and everything
um there's a few things that I want to
particularly touch on with this
application and I do apologize my laptop
has decided to kind of freeze on me so I
can't really flick through
um the the report but there's a few
things I want to touch on the first one
is that it's deemed uh within the report
that this is outside of the village
confines there's many things that are
outside the village confines that get
built on in the villages on a very
frequent basis
um I know I'm probably one of as a
former Ward member from Sonic Villages
I'm always a very strong proponent for
protecting the village confines but
particularly the scale of this and the
fact that it is one single dwelling
located next to as Mr Richard said uh to
uh Huckleberry Farm
um I think it's you know it's really
important we provide that context that
you know this is one dwelling owned by a
family that are very local and have
owned this land for a number of years
um so I think it's important that that's
that's
um understood and one of the reasons
it's been given uh for uh wanting to
refuse permission to this is pressure on
the special protection area
um
I think it's important that members of
the committee know that further down
down Barton Road right towards the end
is a large collection of farm buildings
that are operated known by Saint
Nicholas Court Farm particularly when it
comes to you know the views and of the
open Countryside I would argue that they
do look quite quite striking none of
them look particularly Heritage or old
in Mana they're huge massive metal steel
construction I'm not for one minute
saying that they shouldn't be there um
it's farm buildings they're there for a
reason but I think it's important that
you know this is a one a one-story
three-bed single dwelling and to provide
that context it's not exactly going to
stick out on the open landscape
particularly in that section of
downbarton Road
finally um there was a part in the in
the report and it may be uh a
misspelling or it says a policy spo1
says that limited development
um is allocated in The Villages and it's
primarily allocated to Moncton only
um which I'm quite surprised about
because we've just had the tophill
street application come before this
committee about well a couple of hours
ago
um you know and again I I would like to
emphasize that considering the size of
this development and and how sustainable
you can argue these smaller develops are
it's really important that we encourage
measured development within the villages
otherwise residents move away and
there's no real connection to the local
area and that that kind of community is
is lost
um this development is going to be
largely self-contained there's going to
be parking on site I appreciate that
there's not going to be a footpath sorry
chair I'll just quickly wrap up that
there won't be a pavement to the site
but as I've already said previously with
other previous applications instant
Nicholas if that was put to practice
with a lot of half the homes in St
Nicholas wouldn't be suitable because
normally you step straight out onto the
road but therefore I would like to urge
the committee to um to Grant permission
to this application thank you
thank you um the principal planning
officer will now outline the report
so thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red
um reference has been made sorry this is
down Belton Road
um running across the bottom of the site
reference excuse me has been made to the
glamping site which is located to the
rear of the application site and around
here and there is also a dwelling that
members approved some time ago in this
location adjacent to the site here
so this is an aerial photograph of the
site
so the application site is here
this is the site where the dwelling has
been approved by members some time ago
and the glamping site around it but
members will clearly see that there is
sporadic development along down Barton
Road but it is very much a sort of
agricultural environment and
and as you obviously go further towards
the village you've got summer road
coming off there and then you're heading
off towards the village is where the
main sort of residential development
kicks in but in the very surrounding
area it is very much agricultural open
Countryside
so we're looking
sorry up down Barton Road so
um the application site would be further
down on your left hand side but that's
the summer road coming off here so you
can see some houses there
and this is looking the upper way so the
application site is now on your right
um and the access to the application
site is just about here where this
structure is
and this is actually a view
standing in the axis of the site looking
across to the opposite side of down
Barton Road just showing the openness of
the site so beyond the hedges it's again
agricultural fields
so this is the access gate to the site
you can see it has been used it is an
access but it isn't formalized it's not
paved or
you know it is more of an agricultural
field access it has that feel to it
so we're now I'm now standing at the
gate as you can see the edge of the gate
there looking into the application site
so you can see they are is a structure
on the site and you are looking at
towards you can just see and the roofs
of a glamping cabin on the adjoining
site there again this is looking into
the application site but looking the
opposite the other way so you can get a
feel for the site so there is some
planting on the site that appears to be
Conifer sort of planting there
um this is a view looking back towards
the application site so it's in this
location there this is an access which
you can just see a sort of post there
but it's the access to the glamping site
that runs
um around and there's access to the site
here to the glamping site and you can
see it as a glamping cabin there and
this is a view further away so that's
the same poll we saw there and again you
can see the structures on the glamping
site here
so this is the proposed site plan for
the proposal
so the access road and gate would be
formalized so that would be paved so
you'd get a more traditional domestic
access into the site
the light green trees are existing
yeah the light green trees you can see
on this all circles I'm not too sure how
it looks probably more circular are
existing trees the darker green ones are
proposedry so there will be some
additional planting
um and again that this is a hedging we
saw and there is again the light green
sort of hedging is existing and there's
a small area of additional hedging here
but you can see the dwelling would sit
in this location here and this would be
its amenity space here with access and
parking and there's a small shed shown
here for cycle parking in general sort
of
domestic use
so this is the front elevation
as proposed as has been mentions it's
single story in height
and so that's the view that would be
seen
facing onto down Barton Road
this is the cell the side Innovation
Facing East so that's the site that
would face
onto the sort of area where the existing
dwelling that members approved some time
ago sits
um this is the rear elevation so that
would face
um behind North down Road onto the
Garden area
um
and that's the side
the west elevation which would be facing
out onto the open Countryside so as has
been mentioned it is a single story
dwelling it has a footprint of some 140
square meters and a Ridge High to 4.5
meters as you can see there
and from the drawing
so you've got the main bedrooms looking
at the floor plan of it the main
bedrooms and bathrooms are situated in
the eastern part of the dwelling
there's a Terrace to the rear here and
the main sort of living accommodation
sort of day-to-day living and dining
area is in the western end of the
proposed dwelling and you can see the
large glazed areas or windows that we
looked out here
uh we looked at in the previous
elevation
and that's just the root plan of the
site
um
so in terms of sort of summarizing
members it's not considered there would
be any adverse impacts from The Proposal
on highways
it is noticed there isn't a footpath as
has been mentioned by Council of Pugh to
the village in this location but members
when granting the um
dwelling on the adjoining side found
that not to be an issue so we found it
40 unreasonable that we could
add that as a reason for refusal
to this application
there's no adverse impact in terms of
drainage ecology
archeology
or the living conditions of surrounding
occupiers
um
or if there are any impacts they could
be dealt with by conditions
and it is considered that the dwelling
itself would provide a good standard of
accommodation for its future occupiers
the main concerns however is that whilst
the dwelling would result in a
contribution of a single dwelling
and that would contribute to the um
shortfall in the housing land Supply
albeit a very small contribution
and it also has a benefit of
um being a self-built property where
it's there is an identified need for in
the district
and in the actual development of the
single dwelling wood in itself provides
some economic benefits during
construction employing people Etc
um so there is some weight to be given
to the benefits of this development
but this needs to be weighed by members
against
um the fact that the site is located in
the countryside it is outside the
village confines
um and it is sort of in a land landscape
character area which identifies
um Open Fields and farmland narrable
um land of that nature
and and it's characterized for its
openness and Rural appearance so the
erection of a dwelling in this location
would be visible in Long views
particularly from the west of the site
and particularly where we saw those
large glazed windows
and it is considered of course severe
harm to the interest intrinsic character
and beauty of the countryside and the
landscape character area
so the recommendation is that it is
contrary to the policies SP 24 SB 26 and
qdo2 at the local plan
and this needs to be given significant
weight when members weigh up the
proposal
so the overall the environmental harm
is considered to outweigh the modest
benefits that are would be occurred from
this grant um being built out
and in addition there is a technical
reason to refuse or that the applicants
have failed to enter into to mitigate
against the Press
provide an acceptable form mitigation
sorry to relieve the pressure on the SBA
so there is a technical reason for a
refusal but it is acknowledged that that
could be overcome by the submission of a
unilateral undertaking to secure that
contribution but as it currently stands
the recommendation is for refusal thank
you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted can the vice
chair please second
thank you
and who wants to speak
firstly cancer album
thank you chair
um
severely detrimental
don't think so
um
not in my opinion
the amount of work
that was undertaken on the land to the
side and to the back of this this site
by what is now called goosberry Farm or
whatever it was
um
there's been a load of development there
I don't know whether the person who owns
that land lives there or not I haven't
got a clue
whilst the actual design of the building
is a bit less wanting in my in my
opinion as well
but
for me this small piece of land as it
sits there with the Gooseberry Farm
surrounding it
um
I think it's absolutely fine I think the
absolute use of that land is fine
for there I'm sure as the uh in relation
to the uh any legal agreement that's
needed I mean obviously we should we
determine this for for approval that
that
can be uh obviously they we would put a
condition in relation to that unilateral
agreement that they must that must be in
place
and dealt with prior to any consent
being being granted but
I don't see it as detrimental at all I
think that's that you know I could even
I would understand if it was further
down but in that part there plus you've
got one that's next door going to be
built I just can't see it's it's a
problem thank you
[Music]
actually Council organ said a lot I was
going to say I was just going to ask the
officer why the one next door what had
changed that was approved in May 2020 I
know that was before the local plan was
adopted but
um was there any particular reason why
that would have been permitted other
than the local plan and this one you're
recommending refusal
uh as in the site to the east
members refused it against sorry
approved it against officers advice
it was approved yes
that's my point it was approved I mean
it was time for refusal hence the
reference are
um Reserve matters but it was approved
although you recommended refuse or
you're recommending refusal for this one
but that one next door Within
few meters has got approval
councilor matkinson
I was wondering what the finish on the
house was it's um shown as Stripes it's
obviously not brickwork
and what's the roof made of
yeah the details we've been given into
this gives me in terms of materials is
composite roof material and essentially
cladding to the walls
no I assuming boarding rather than but
I'm not sure if it's plastic or
wouldn't
counselor bayford
thank you chair
um I agree with the comments made by
councilman and
um councilman at a face
I I think the um the external finishes
irrelevant it's very very it's a single
story dwelling I really cannot see that
this can be described as causing
considerable harm
um and I feel that even from the office
of report the benefits clearly outweigh
the disadvantages so I'm afraid I don't
agree with your recommendation thank you
foreign
yeah I have to agree with my other
counselors um I don't see a problem with
this especially in the site that it's on
it's enclosed in that rectangle
um just evens out the site might as well
go go where it uh where where it's
proposed um I don't have an issue with
it and would be I'm afraid against the
officer's recommendation
counselor wing
he's just use the dodgy mic
and because I think it's very Barn like
so it sort of fits in it fits in the
area I I and I you know it's great to
see that this will be in a sense an
affordable build because it's going to
be a self-build for a family that
possibly couldn't afford to live in the
village sadly or possibly any other part
of Fanny at the minute the only concern
I would have slight concern is are we
setting a precedent we've approved one
we've proved this one there's another
bit of land come up so that that would
be the only thing that would would be
giving me a little bit of a niggle but
you know I I have a mind to support it
because I think it's a good development
and councilor more yes thank you chair
um I just format the committee members I
think the actual external would be
timbercladding or something so that's
going to weather in and with the
additional trees that were on the
drawings being being planted that's
going to blend in even more I mean
agreement with my fellow committee
members that I think the officers wrong
in this case
I think it's sustainable I think it's
well thought out it is like an
agricultural building in some ways which
will blend in in that landscape so I
cannot go with the officer's
recommendation thank you
okay I think at that point um we're
getting a very similar message and I'm
going to put the motion for the
officer's recommendation for refusal to
the vote can I have those in favor of
refusal please
and those against
and that's uh definitely lost so we now
need to come up with an alternative
motion and I think the officer is about
to give us a draft
thank you
um so members have clearly expressed
that they consider the benefits of the
room in our way the any any perceived
harm to the countryside and character
appears the area so the the motion that
we'd recommend in this instance given
that the motion's Fallen would be to
approve subject to the submission of an
acceptable legal agreement securing the
Sam's contribution
um and that would be approved on the
basis that the benefits the development
outweigh any harm to the character
appearance of the area
question share
could I ask as well that um
if the if the legal agreement is not
entered into this comes back to members
please
um so if yeah if well if it doesn't come
back to well if we don't get a legal
agreement and the application just won't
be determined
um what we would usually do and we'll
come on to this with Park Lane later is
we'll put a six month expectation that
comes in in that period of time can I
just clarify something with regards to
the motion we did receive comments from
console tease that you will have seen
and therefore um things prudent to
potentially add safeguarding conditions
related to what the Consultants have
requested on that basis and if members
are happy to delegate that to officers
on the basis that it will be approved
subject to the legal agreement and
safeguarding conditions to deal with
those matters
uh I'll propose what Mr Livingston has
just said here
okay I think councilor Moore I saw your
hand go up first for the seconding was
that right that's right Jeff okay thank
you and can I have all those in favor of
the motion
thank you that's carried
okay so the next item on the agenda is
16 Seoul Street broadstairs firstly
speaking under Council rule 20.1 is
councilor Kevin pressland
thank you chair thank you members for
letting me have this opportunity to
relay my concerns about this development
you'll see on the plan that there is a
drive coming in and parking areas there
and there is
um a proposal for five of the mature
trees on that site to be removed because
the rpas will be compromised or a
percentage of the rpas will be
compromised by the drive and also the
parking area
but whilst I agree that there is clearly
going to impact one of the trees
particularly and that which we will will
go there the four other trees the
percentage of the RPA could be actually
retained by a system called a terram
geocell 2020 tree root protection system
which is a permeable 3D cellular soil
confinement system and using this this
particular system it actually safeguards
the roots of the trees so it doesn't go
into the ground but it just goes
slightly above the ground with this
cellular system which has the a gravel
and a silt in between which allows
permeability and watering of the root
system below
so this could Safeguard those roots
whilst allowing that development to take
place so my question to the count to to
the members here is is could the there
be Amendment to the plan in the and on
the basis that that said type of system
be used
so that those four trees that could be
retained uh will be retained and also to
say that you know increasingly we're
losing lots of mature trees in thanet
and mature trees have a whole biodiverse
habitat associated with them and by just
planting five other trees as is proposed
so the five trees lost is not any by any
means compensation for those lost trees
and I just like to bring members to the
attention that there is a professional
methodology which has been produced by
the aborough culture Association
um and um
are other professional bodies within
that sector that Karen McKenzie the
three Warden abroad says actually has uh
details of which um show actually the
amount of trees that should be used to
compensate to any degree the loss of
those trees so I I asked the I urge the
committee to ask for Amendment of the
application so the trees are retained
and the proposed terram geocell system
used as an another Sim or another
similar product thank you for
um thank you cheers
thank you the principal planning officer
will now outline the report
sorry it's me
um
so the application site is in the center
of the screen so this is a previous
planning application that was considered
by members um a couple of years ago now
um for Seoul Street and the erection of
four dwellings on the site
um so the site has a blanket uh TPO on
it so it's an aerial order from 1974 and
one of the key issues was what happens
to the trees on the site when we're
agreeing to for it to be developed so
this is a 3D which doesn't quite show
the extent of the tree coverage that you
have on the site when In Bloom so if we
go down to street level on Seoul Street
you can see the trees at the front of
the site so these trees are all being
retained and these are covered by the
TPO from 1974.
so this is one View and then this is
just a view looking the other way
um then this is at the rear of the site
at Crawford Road uh looking towards the
trees so the trees that we were just
looking at are in this area here there
is a a large tree which we'll see in a
minute
um which is adjacent to the neighboring
property
um which is is also proposed now to be
retained as well and then this is a bit
of a view further back so the trees that
um were sort of the submission that we
got in with the planning application
which showed the trees in the
agricultural survey that was done
identified uh every tree on the site
pretty much as a sea grade tree with a
uh the the odd B and some some U trees
so when they're grading that that BC
means it's the num the amount of years
that they've got left as well as the
immunity value and the actual
um the health of the tree itself from
from The observed server that was done
now with the trees that I just want to
draw your attention to uh members um
specifically the trees that are affected
by this proposal is 1C which is uh
whether my mouse is is going around
there it's 7c and 8C so it's these two
trees here
and then it's 15 U which is here so
previously this proposed this
application was proposing to remove five
of the trees that were previously
safeguarded and that was the big tree
that we saw which is um 16b that's now
to be retained so the proposal is to
remove uh the trees that are the spread
of which is provided in red uh the
rationale that's been provided relates
to
um when the further survey work's been
done for the agricultural method
statement which has to be submitted as
one of the conditions on the original
approval the chartered agriculturalist
has indicated that those trees in his
view cannot cannot be retained in their
current positions but all the other
trees that are outlined in the dotted
black lines are still to be retained now
this is um I suppose slightly unique in
one sense that the application was
approved on the grounds of the the there
should be adherence to the plans and
there was a plan that said You know here
are the trees that should be retained
these trees that are to be removed are
not considered to be covered by the TPO
from 1974 for they're not old enough and
therefore
um technically they could have been
removed before any proposal without sen
however the condition was put on to
ensure that you know all the trees are
retained and so the debate in particular
regards the trees is whether or not the
loss of these trees is considered to
result in harm to the character
appearance of the area uh and the you
know and the immunity that's offered by
these specific trees and that has to be
weighed against obviously the fact that
this would be a reason for refusal
effectively refusing four houses on the
basis of these four trees now
in terms of the detail then just to zoom
in a little bit closer you can see that
again the spread of the trees again the
the Charles de agriculturist report
indicates that the tree that's got the
largest spread that was set behind that
tree so you can can't see it from the
road
um is is a it's a category u tree so
it's not expected to to live for more
than 10 years from this point and then
the other trees are obviously relatively
small in terms of their
um their Span in comparison with the
trees at the front so in our view those
trees can be removed without harming the
character and appearance of the area the
other change that is occurring as part
of the application is that one of the
other conditions required adherence to
this plan which shows the section and
the land levels of the dwellings
themselves just to give you some context
the the building that's on the left hand
side is the neighboring property
um if I go back to this plan you can
actually see that that dwelling is set
quite significantly further back sorry
so further forward
right on the road with the dwelling
being set behind it was considered the
distance is sufficient between the side
elevation of unit 4 and the rear extent
of of the name and property number 16.
but what's changing here is the land
level is changing to ensure that the
drainage would work within the dwelling
and it's increasing in height by
22 centimeters 22.5 centimeters so that
is included within the proposal as well
so overall it's considered that we don't
consider the the work that we carried
out would harm the character and
appearance of the area
significantly to Warrant reviews of the
application given that the proposal
would obviously you know continue to
provide the retention of the trees that
provide the significant amenity value on
the site as well as the provision of
four dwellings and therefore it's
recommended for approval thank you
moves that the officer's recommendation
has adopted can the vice chair please
second seconded
thank you do I have any speakers uh I
will start with councilor Garner and
thank you yeah I mean
um I called the original application in
to be discussed by the planning
committee
um it was while we were having meetings
online so I I looked at it today because
um just to remind myself we we were all
cons I called him because I was
concerned about the loss of trees those
of us who spoke in the in the debate on
that application Express their concern
about the loss of trees and the reason
we approved the application unanimously
we all approved including me was because
we got assurance
that these four houses could be built
and the trees all the trees on the site
could be retained
these trees all have a player
significant have a significant impact on
the character of that area I mean I will
say there is a tree right at the bottom
of South Street that was removed a
couple of weeks ago for the for various
reasons with permission but as these as
councilor president has indicated as
these trees
um are lost
the biodiversity is severely affected
now this applicant
assured us they could build these four
houses without losing any trees at all
now they've come back now and said we
can't build the four houses without
losing any trees and we want to lose
these four trees now we've heard from
Council of prison that there are ways of
doing this without losing these trees
and they should be investigated
or if they can't build four houses
without losing any of the trees then
maybe they need to reconsider the number
of houses and the size of the houses
that they put on that plot but I think
it is imperative that we stand firm and
say no trees should be lost on this plot
as we did previously
so I mean I'm happy to listen to others
to be persuaded otherwise but as it
stands I will be voting to refuse this
application
councilor Kane
okay again the officers comment on
councilor pressland's suggestions for
the trees is that viable
I can't comment on it it's not under
consideration it's the removal of the
trees and whether or not that is the
sufficient reason for refusal obviously
we have the report which is on the on
the website which is submit by the
applicant giving the childhood
agriculturalist view on on the retention
of the trees and why they in the view of
of the applicant can't be retained but
it is a it's a it's a straight merits
decision as to whether or not this would
warrant reviews of the application
councilman
yes thank you chair um I take it that
the Arborio report was obviously paid by
the applicant to have done so that lends
itself that I think that sometimes
that's weighted towards the applicant
um and I agree with councilor Garner's
views that we agreed this unanimously on
the basis that all the trees would be
saved and therefore the applicant needs
to look into ways to do that to get what
he wants and and I agree with councilor
Garner if he can't do that then he needs
to reduce what he's doing will reduce
the size so I've I would not be in favor
of approving this thank you
I just want to come back on on that
um
when professional reports are obviously
instructed by applicants I think it's
really important to distinguish between
when you have in this instant someone
that is a chartered member of the
Agricultural Association that's
preparing a report they are required to
adhere to certain codes of Conduct in
terms of recommendations or not and so I
think in terms of the weight that's
given to what the applicant submission
is that is obviously something that is
quite relevant in terms of
the principle behind the retention of
trees at all costs a reminder these
trees are not protected under the TPO
they were originally considered that
obviously with all of the trees that the
applicant put forward the fact that they
were looking to retain them all
um they have obviously put in the
application rather than for you know
call you know having anything happen on
site or anything like that I do think
it's important that the merits of the
overall application have to be taken
into account when determining this we
have all of the protected trees being
being retained and the provision of four
dwellings on a site in the urban
confines when we have a need for housing
as identified by the lack of fiber
Supply so I just need to stress that
thank you you want to come back in
councilman yes please yeah um so if he's
a chartered or boilers then would he
also have the knowledge that was brought
to the table this evening about these
other methods and if he is uh I'd say
treat hugger or you know as we call them
sometimes
um surely he would have those those
propositions to put forward to people
like the clients who say there are ways
of doing this and I don't think that's
been done so I think that night that
might need to be looked at
councilor Mata face
take a slightly different approach one
of the objection says there's no
pavement on the side of the road now
these are four presumably quite large
houses I know Seoul Street very well
having walked my children to school for
many years along it's a very narrow road
and my concern I know I was obviously I
wasn't involved when you approved it is
actually traffic coming out into that
narrow road but I appreciate we're
actually looking at a slightly different
aspect but I am quite concerned about
four big houses on there although yes
you've got to tell me it's not relevant
at the minute but it is relevant to
people who walk along that road
during the day at school time
particularly
[Music]
yeah you're quite right I'm going to
tell you it's it's been it was
considered in the original outline of
occasion it was considered in the
original application when it was
approved we're only looking at the
change the the two changes the loss of
the trees and the change to plot unit
four in terms of that um that land level
councilor wing
why are the trees going what is the
reason that the developer promised in
the previous uh application uh that he
could save all the trees or they could
save all the trees and now suddenly
Something's Happened and they can no
longer save those trees they could
shrink the size of the houses and we'd
still get four properties
to help our housing shortage the other
thing I'd like to add is I think the
system that that councilor pressland is
talking about was used by KCC to save
the Tree near Ellington school it's a
cherry tree that's been there a number
of years the only tree that offers kids
and parents shade in the summer it's on
the corner cars park on top of it so and
it's proved I think it's been done two
years now the tree's been okay the
area's been okay so I certainly think we
need to if if the Builder's saying he's
now got to cut these trees down we need
to understand why he can't keep them and
whether he's explored the alternatives
to trying to keep those trees and
whether new technologies can be used
um so so I've zoomed in here it relates
to the the hard surfacing for the access
to for the parking of the dwellings so
the dwellings themselves it's not an
issue with regards to say foundations
affecting uh rpas or anything like that
it's it's in relation to where the
parking access is obviously the aim here
is to try and get you've got the visitor
parking that's on site as well
um obviously again it leads to Links
actually to the fact of what customers
face was saying in terms of parking off
off any potential off the road which is
why there's a visitor lay-by that you
can see is obviously causing an impact
on the tree to the the very north of
that picture that's in red
um so that that is the The View that's
been put forward by the applicant and um
with regards to trees that that need to
be removed as part of that plan by the
uh the arbor culturalist as I say I
can't speak to the the
um you know the the potential method
that could be used there
um as I say thank you
I've still got two more to speak
councilor Auburn first
thank you chair yeah I'm um the easiest
thing
is to approve this application isn't it
um but I like my fellow counselors here
um when the application was first being
considered
the applicant was quite happy for those
trees to be retained
and what is the difference between then
and now and the answer to that is
nothing
nothing is different between then and
now because the roadway was going to go
in anyway so they knew about the the
roadway the parking and everything like
that and there was and they were quite
happy to leave those four four trees
there so um I'm I have to say that um
I'm not in agreement with this thank you
so I just come back in on what's changed
the albacultural method statement that
members required as part of the approval
it was a condition saying you've got to
submit a method statement they've done
the method statement to look at being
able to protect all those trees and in
their view they can't protect all those
trees on the on that basis in terms of
the point about
um what was put forward again I keep
buying it come back to the point about
the merits of this I appreciate that
members have been told all the trees
they're looking to retain all the trees
but it's still got to be a judgment
that's not based on what was promised
but actually what's in front of members
and what's in front of members is a
proposal that is actually for you know
whether or not that actually those four
trees specifically the quality of those
four trees the visibility of those four
trees and the removal of those four
trees would actually result in a reason
for a few that outweighs four dwellings
on the site I just think I'm sorry to
keep stressing it but it is really
important the members do consider the
weight on that
um council president
excuse me
um I've got councilor bayford next
please
thank you chair yeah I'm very torn here
because I am concerned about the
potential loss of four new homes
but I do accept
what other members have said and it does
seem that the only
the only way
um
that these trees are going to be
retained it is to for us to refuse it
tonight and for the applicant to come
back with a new application is there no
other option here
um if
um
I I do not know in terms of the
discussion between the officer and the
applicant um because obviously we looked
at it again on the merits of the case
um if members weren't going to vote to
approve it and that motion Falls
um then a member could propose a motion
to say defer to officers to seek
um you know further negotiation with the
applicant around whether or not any of
the trees could be retained with
alternative measures being used
um you know to what council president
was mentioning
um so we could seek that rather than
refuse it outright on the value judgment
obviously again that does come with an
element of risk because as we had with
the the application at Stone Road there
is obviously the ability of an applicant
to appeal non-determination against the
council obviously we would look to seek
to resolve and provide what members are
clearly expressing that they would want
to see as much work done as possible to
make sure these trees are retained but
that that is the decision for for
members as to whether or not
um that is an option but it does it does
come with an element of risk I have to
power on that as well
councilor ratkin
um and you certainly trees are not
protected so basically the landowner
could just chop chop them Chop Chop them
down
um and any anyway
um am I correct well not quite because
it's part of a planning condition if
they were to remove them as part of
developing the site it would be a breach
of the planning condition in the event
of that they didn't develop the site the
planning permission elapsed say
um they could remove the trees and then
come in with an application for you know
the development again without those
trees being there but obviously as it's
a condition on the approval it links to
the development itself
counselor wing
I mean looking at the uh you you
mentioned hard standing so I mean
straight away the jiggling of the
parking below could move up to save that
one tree and I also noticed that that if
you look at unit one the line from the
boundary to the fence is I think it's
10.1 meters and then 10.8 meters so I
mean if there was a re-jigging of those
buildings on that site to maybe create
some of the garden space in in front of
the buildings and behind the buildings
like we often see in a bit of a creative
way uh maybe maybe more of those trees
could be saved so you know I think they
need to go away and they need to look at
that Hard standing and see if they can
re-jig or move the buildings about or
reduce the size of that that the size of
the gut the length of the garden at the
back and create some more at the front I
don't know but you know they said they'd
save them and they've come back and said
they can't
I'm not happy
okay I think we will move to the vote
um so to put the motion for the
officer's recommendation for approval
how many in favor of approval
six
and against
and abstentions
then it's Fallen
thank you chair um so obviously as we've
discussed um in in the in the fact that
the motion has fallen uh officers
recommend that it's deferred to officers
to seek alternative measures and or
changes to the layout to seek the
retention of the trees and then to bring
that back to members
[Music]
I I didn't have to say a word there did
I
I'm not necessarily going to um object
to that but I would like to emphasize
and I think I hope that we would like to
emphasize that the any solution that
comes back any application that comes
back needs to see zero loss of any trees
thank you
um I think what we'll look what we will
have to do is obviously find out for the
applicant fundamentally the
decision-making authorities with members
okay so officers can't we can return it
to you with not you know with uh three
trees removed and one you can make a
decision on the basis of that and what
we will do is we will see if we can
conclude discussions and we will bring
you back what we've been able to get and
then you will be able to make a decision
on that
so the motion is to defer and bring back
I have a proposer and a seconder for
that
um anyone who wants to vote in favor
that's carried thank you
so that concludes the public speaking
for this meeting I will now call upon
the clock to read out the remaining
planning applications if any member
wishes to reserve an application will
they please call out as the clock reads
thank you
thank you chair
so uh we have 801 banned on the south
east side of manston road manston
airport Northern grass Margate
we have a06 and adjacent to Harbor
Masters office and public toilets Harbor
Street broadstairs
we have a07 which is also that adjacent
to Harbor Masters office and public
toilets Harbor Street broadstairs
we have a08 Victoria Gardens Victoria
Parade broadstairs
a09 Margate Clock Tower Marine Drive
Margate
a 10 eight Buckley Gardens Margate
a11 flat 1
189 High Street broadstairs thank you
Jim
thank you can I have a proposer to move
that the applications that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the officer's recommendations
Council album and secondary councilor
roseki
do members agree
thank you
okay one abstain
um for the
one
that's awesome
Stephen to read them all out again yeah
for the benefit of the public I will
call upon the cloud to read out the
applications that have been determined
thank you thank you chair
so the applications that have been
determined are a05 land on the Southeast
side of manston road manston airport
Northern grass Margate 806 land adjacent
to Harbor Masters office and public
toilets Harbor Street broadstairs
a07 land adjacent to Harbor Masters
office and public toilets Harbor Street
broadstairs
808 Victoria Gardens Victoria Parade
809 Margate Clock Tower Marine Drive
Margate
A10 eight Plucky Gardens Margate
and a11 flat 1 189 High Street
rhyme skate
thank you chair
thank you
to enjoy item five our gender item five
sorry
I've lost I've lost a piece of paper we
have an agenda item five hold on a
minute
my apologies
um speaking under Council rule 20.1 is
counselor Rhys Pugh
thank you chair I'm sorry I I want us
all to go home as much as you do don't
worry I'll be very quick very quick
but if you look if you go the way I want
then I'll be even quicker um I I'm
speaking here tonight uh mainly because
uh chair of birch and Parish council's
planning committee
um was unable to speak on on this plan
application so I have a bit of a
statement uh that I'm just going to
quickly read out
um Robert Wright chair of the parish
council's planning committee was not at
the original meeting considering this
application uh he was on sick leave he
has since looked at the amended plan for
six dwellings and would still agree with
the original council's comments of
overdevelopment of the site and
inadequate parking provision had the
site surface area been 1.5 larger than
it actually is there would be no reason
to refuse but as it stands it is
overbearing in both height and footprint
especially at two neighbors properties
the second reason to refuse the
application is the lack of parking
provision Park Lane is crowded enough
already six properties equals a minimum
of six cars and the suggestion in the
supporting comments that one can easily
walk into the village is great if one
goes to the shops but it's not does not
address the problem of where the
potential 30 documents of this
development will work although this
development is aimed at first time
buyers and older retired people it is a
fallacy to think that these people would
not want to be owning a car young people
these days
maybe myself included want to own a car
as soon as possible there are at present
nine six formers attending Catholic
School who regularly park across the
road from Canterbury Road and queen
Burgess Avenue as an example
Robert Wright has also noted that in the
published comments that one person
objected to the application and on the
12th of April as published but by the
16th she was all in favor was there
coercion involved in this again members
these are not my comments I'm just
sharing them
um therefore on behalf of Burston Parish
Council I would like to urge you to
refuse permission on this application
thank you
thank you I'll hand to the planning
officer to outline the report thanks
um so the application site is outlined
in Red so this was an application for
six Flats on 15 Park Lane it came before
members last year in July members
resulted to further application for
approval subject to the receipt of a
legal agreement securing the Sam's
contribution with conditions and that
had to occur within six months we didn't
receive that legal agreement within six
months and we have now received the
legal agreement which secures the
contribution but because the deadline
has passed we bring it back to members
the reason why we bring it back to
members is in case policy has changed or
national policy has changed since July
2022 no new policies have been adopted
by the council no changes the mppf which
affect or alter this application in
terms of requiring a redetermination of
any material planning considerations of
the matter
and therefore it's recommended for
approval as no matters of change
resulting in the need for a new
assessment by the committee
so it's down for approval
[Music]
you can move some information yeah sorry
there's a little confusion there it's
getting late
um I move that the officer's
recommendation for approval is adopted
can the vice chair please second
second
anyone wants to speak
in that case we will now put the motion
for the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote all in favor
that's Gary thank you
in which case that does conclude the
business for the meeting thank you for
your attendance and good night